foreign
music
good afternoon everyone
good afternoon
my name is Zach kirkhorn I lead Finance
here at Tesla and Welcome to our
investor day
[Applause]
for those of you here in the audience at
our Global Headquarters in Austin Texas
we welcome you thank you for being here
and thank you for traveling in
for those joining us virtually thank you
for being a part of the day today
so as we reflect back on the history of
the company there's been distinct phases
of product advancement Technology
Innovation and Rapid volume growth
the most recent of which has been the
global expansion and localization of the
model y program
and so today we want to talk about the
future
we don't want to talk about this quarter
or next quarter we want to go further
out into the future
and we've divided today's presentation
into three parts
the first of which we're going to go
macro
what does it take to convert Earth to
sustainable energy generation and use
the second we want to talk about Tesla's
contribution to that Global need
we're going to go function by function
through the company and you'll meet our
entire leadership team and we're going
to get into the details of what those
teams are doing
as part of the broader goal
and then in the third part
we're going to bring it back up and talk
about what this all means for the
company as a whole
so before we get started statements made
in this presentation are forward-looking
statements that are subject to risks and
uncertainties more details can be found
in our written materials
so with that let's get started
part one Elon Musk and Drew baglino
[Applause]
all right master plan part three
so
as
Zach was mentioning that the thing that
I think is we wanted to convey probably
more importantly than anything else that
we talk about here is that there is a
clear path to a sustainable energy Earth
it's not
it doesn't require
destroying natural habitats it doesn't
uh
require
has to be austere and stop using
electricity and sort of be in the cold
or anything
um the the story and I think that this
holds together quite well and will be
actually publishing uh detailed white
paper with all of our assumptions and
calculations is that there is that there
is a clear path to a fully sustainable
Earth uh with abundance in fact you
could support a civilization much bigger
than Earth than much more than the the
eight billion humans could actually be
supported sustainably on Earth
and I'm I'm just often shocked and
surprised by how few people realize this
um
most of the smart people I know actually
don't see a those clear path they think
that
um
there's there's not a path to a
sustainable energy future or at least
there's not one that
is sustainable at our current population
or that would have to
resort to Extreme Measures
none of this is true
so we're going to walk through the
calculations for how to create a
sustainable energy civilization
yeah
and to set the stage today our energy
economy
it's let's be honest it's sturdy and
it's wasteful over 80 percent of global
energy primary energy comes from fossil
fuels and only one-third of that Global
energy actually ends up delivering
useful work or heat
this is the problem statement but we're
here to talk about the solution
yeah it's like if for some of this I'm
going to elaborate because there's
there's a very wide range of technical
expertise uh out there from people who
are like you know whatever level 9
Wizards in the subject to people who do
not do engineering at all so if you have
a gasoline car
your
your you're converting less than a third
often maybe only 25 percent of the
energy in the gasoline is converted into
motion the rest is turning to waste heat
that does no doesn't do any good at all
and there's a lot of energy required
even to get the oil out of the ground to
refine the oil and to transport the
gasoline to the gas station so when you
when you look at all that for a typical
gasoline car is is actually going to be
using less than 20 percent fully
considered of the energy from the oil
actually goes into motion
so this is a when when I see people when
we see people doing calculations for
what does it take to create a
sustainable energy Earth they assume
that the same energy amount is required
for an elect for an electric electrified
civilization versus a combustion
civilization this is not true that
because uh most of the energy of
combustion is waste Heat
and even to get the fuel to combust in
the first place and get it to the end
use there's a lot loss along the way I
mean this is the primary energy
consumption 165 petawatt hours a year
I've had a watt hour is a trillion a
trillion kilowatt hours so it's a large
amount of energy but the nice thing
about an electrified economy it uh
there's a better way we're going to talk
about it is that
through end use efficiency and through
efficiency along every step of the way
actually the total energy use
it halves so this is one of the most
enabling aspects of electrifying
everything is that the sustainable
energy economy is that much easier to
accomplish it's actually half the
problem statement of the fossil fuel
economy yeah and we're being
conservative here so it could be better
than half but uh we're trying to have
assumptions that are reasonable not
overly optimistic in fact slightly
pessimistic so it's really better than
half but just say for it's it's easier
to make the argument that we need half
as much energy with an electric economy
versus a combustion economy yep
um
so how the master plan works you want to
talk yeah
um so
the
the thing that is needed is at very
large scale that is not currently
present is a vast amount of battery
energy storage uh Our rough calculations
are that this is about 240 terawatt
hours or 240 000 gigawatt hours
this is a lot of batteries but it is
actually a very achievable amount uh
we'll go into details on that so that's
a combination of electric vehicles and
stationary storage so if you've got
solar or wind you've got to store the
energy when the wind is not blowing the
sun is not shining and so we're assuming
sort of an 81 ratio of uh stored energy
to power so 30 terawatt hours of power
30 terawatts of power
um our actual uh
capital expenditure calculation for
manufacturing investment is more like
Six Trillion but we you know we made it
higher to make it 10 trillion and this
is across mining refining you know
battery factories recycling vehicle
factories all the things that we're
going to talk about needing to invest in
to build this sustainable energy economy
yeah now if you look at the total World
economy it's just under 100 trillion so
if this was spread out say over 10 years
it would be one percent of the global
economy over 20 years it would be half a
percent very difficult economy so this
is uh yeah
not a big number relative to the global
economy
um as Drew mentioned you need about half
as much energy with an electric economy
versus a combustion economy and in terms
of wind and solar how much land would be
used it's less than 0.2 percent of the
land area of Earth
um
like generally people don't realize
quite how much energy is reaching us
from the sun
it's roughly a gigawatt per square
kilometer
um
and you know the sun doesn't shine all
the time but it's uh if you multiply
that by say uh
four to get the continuous power four or
five uh then that that that gives you
the land area of solar and you can put
wind and solar often in the same place
so a lot of places that currently have
wind you could have solar there and you
double your energy you can also put wind
offshore it doesn't even need to be on
land so wind is even more flexible you
could put solar offshore too yeah so
Earth is 70 water
um anyway what is that
um with a pretty really remarkably small
amount of of Earth's land area we can go
fully sustainable
um
yeah and and and from uh to the
resources and raw materials exist to
support this transition uh we'll go
through that in detail but we do not see
any insurmountable resource challenges
at all in fact in the end we should be
um mining less ore to accomplish this
economy than we currently do with the
fossil fuel economy and we're going to
talk through that yeah just to emphasize
that again the electrified economy will
require less mining than the current
economy does yes less not more okay
um so this is the plan and now we'll get
into a little bit more of the details of
the plan
basically five areas of work
first early power the existing grid
second switch to the to electric
vehicles third switch homes businesses
and Industry heating to heat pumps uh
fourth high temp heat delivery and
storage for high temp industrial and
chemical processes and a little bit of
green hydrogen in there for chemical
porosities that need hydrogen
and finally sustainable sustainably fuel
planes and boats these are the five
areas and we're going to go into detail
on all of them yeah I mean my personal
opinion is that as we improve the energy
density of batteries you'll see old
Transportation go fully electric with
the
exception of rockets that's awkward
um but uh but you can make the fuel with
uh CO2 and water so you can make methane
with CO2 and water so in fact that with
just electricity yes exactly so uh so in
fact on Mars if we hopefully get there
at some point the atmosphere is CO2 and
there's water ice throughout Mars so you
can take the CO2 and H2O and turn that
into CH4 which is methane and oxygen so
ultimately even Rockets can be
electrified
so first repowering the existing grid
with Renewables and this is going to be
a consistent theme you'll see our
estimates for the number of terawatt
hours terawatts and trillions of
investment at the bottom of the page
you know this is already actively
occurring in front of US 60 of the
generation added to the US grid was
solar in 2022 and actually on a year on
year basis solar deployment is growing
50 year on year as of 2022. so this is a
this is a serious uh uh upswing and if
we continue this trend this is going to
be behind us before we even know it yeah
um
second switching to electric vehicles
again 21 uh reduction in fossil fuel use
by doing this alone
obviously Tesla is heavily engaged in
this activity as along with many others
overall EV production grew 59 year on
year in 2022 and Evie's hit an amazing
10 market share I mean it's an awesome
Milestone I I've I'm super excited to
see that and I gotta yeah I mean this is
uh
obviously happening very rapidly
and I mean I think
really all cars will go to fully
electric and autonomous
and so writing a non-autonomous gasoline
car is going to be analogous riding a
horse and using a flip phone that's
basically going to be the situation and
we actually took a somewhat conservative
assumption here in terms of how many
batteries are required because the more
the fleet is autonomous the the fewer
the smaller the fleet needs to be just
from a utility basis so we're not
accounting for all of those benefits
really much of those benefits at all in
this number
and what does this Fleet look like you
know just rough view from our
perspective of course we could be wrong
but you know you can see the sort of
breakdown of the fleet by millions of
vehicles you know our goal is to do 20
million electric vehicles a year yeah
fewer Vehicles will be needed at least
passenger vehicles uh with autonomy so
um
there's some debate as to what that
number is but it's it's some number less
than the number of vehicles needed today
there's roughly two billion cars and
trucks
in operation in the world today
yeah so what we show here is actually I
think only 1.4 million or so
so we're we're represent 1.4 billion I
mean or so so a smaller Fleet and you
know that the numbers are here in this
presentation are around 85 million
Vehicles a year produced just to give
you a sense of how we're thinking about
this again we're going to put all these
assumptions up online and you know
encourage people's thoughts yeah
so
yeah so we're basically heading rapidly
towards an electric or autonomous future
exciting yeah
um and one of the reasons why EVS are so
enabling is this end use efficiency
Point
um
Tesla Model 3 it's four times more
efficient from the well to wheel than a
Toyota Corolla and that's all about the
efficiency of getting the electricity to
the into the car in a sustainable energy
economy and then how efficient the cars
uh in transferring that stored energy to
motion on the road when compared to the
engine in the Toyota Corolla and all the
you know extraction refining
transmission distribution of the
gasoline to the Toyota Corolla and just
for this is a fun reference model 3 can
drive over a mile on the energy it takes
to boil a pot of water for pasta and
then it can drive another mile on the
energy it took to cook the pasta
and that pasta is one pound and all
three is like four thousand pounds just
to give you a sense of just like what
like it really doesn't use a lot of
energy to move a model three that four
thousand pound object down the road also
heat is a lot more energy than motion
yeah yeah but people
people spoil a pot of water you don't
even think about it you know it's just
interesting how efficient these cars are
um next switching to heat pumps in homes
businesses and Industry
um you know right now heat pumps me 10
of building heating needs install rates
growing 10 year on year it really needs
to accelerate heat pumps can serve you
know heat applications up to 200 C in in
businesses and Industry and from an
investment perspective as you can see on
this page it's actually the lowest
hanging fruit in terms of displacing
fossil fuels
um you might be saying well what exactly
is a heat pump so
um
heat pumps don't move heat don't create
heat they move Heat
uh when you think about like the natural
gas furnished in your house like it's it
is generating heat itself but what the
heat pump is doing is actually moving
heat from outside of your house into
your house they're just an air
conditioner or a refrigerator in Reverse
so we're surrounded by heat pumps
there's like
you know they're all over this Factory
they're in your house
um and all this really is is about
bringing them to displace all the fossil
fuel Heating and all the homes business
in in the industry that we can and from
an end us efficiency perspective is a
three three times reduction in the total
energy required to heat these buildings
so a real obvious thing to do yeah heat
pumps they're in our cars yeah not as
default and at some point
we might make a heat pump for our home
so yeah maybe maybe maybe
um next a little bit more detail on
electrifying uh high temp uh sort of
industrial chemical processes
so over 50 of industrial heat is greater
than 400 C where you know cement steel
fertilizers chemicals Plastics Metals
refining all need like 1500 C so we need
a solution here
um ultimately it's purpose-built
equipment that enables electrification
you know Carbon graphite is stable up to
20 100 2800 C there's other options in
the 1500 C range like silicon carbide
other other materials so the idea here
is you create and store heat when
removable power is available if this is
sustainable energy economy you know
renewable energy is intermittent peak of
the day you've got more generation than
you need you make a bunch of heat then
and then you transfer that heat into the
industrial process 24 hours a day using
the stored heat you created when the Sun
or the wind was blowing that's the
concept here and then on the hydrogen
side we also need green hydrogen to
decarbonize metals and chemical refining
processes this is things like ammonia
making steel you know there's roughly
120 million tons of hydrogen sourced
from fossil fuel today to do these
things and hydrogen can also directly
replace coal which is currently used in
a ton of steel production through a
process called directly reducing iron
you can replace blast furnaces with a
hydrogen reducing direct reduced iron
furnace and this is the way to
illuminate fossil fuels from these
aspects of the economy and the CO2
associated with them yeah so I mean
some of this there's like room to
disagree but
some amount of hydrogen is needed for
industrial processes my personal opinion
is that hydrogen will not be used
meaningfully in transport but and
shouldn't be if you're going to use a
chemical fuel you should use ch4.h2
but which was not unless it is needed
for industrial processes and can be
produced just by splitting water
essentially I mean something that's been
done for decades and decades this is not
you know rocket technology
and lastly
a small part of the pie but a necessary
part of the pie is sustainably fueling
planes and boats
um shipping accounts for three percent
of global CO2 it's ripe for
electrification even with lithium iron
phosphate long-haul ships can be fully
battery powered so that's a great
opportunity to Electrify energy density
is a little bit harder for planes but
short Haul is doable today with some
improvements we'll get Long Haul
underway but even even in the meantime
we can leverage sustainable Aviation
fuels produce and storage using access
renewable electricity there's a lot of
work going on in this space and it's
it's it's yeah yeah I mean it to to
really get uh long-range aircraft and
long-range shipping to use uh
lithium ion you need to redesign the
ship and not just
um or the plane and the plane uh
to take advantage of the fact that it is
a new uh source of
energy it's a different architecture so
it just like with an electric car you
wouldn't just you know take a gasoline
car and stick a battery in it that's
very sub-optimal
um it's much more efficient to have the
battery be the structure of the car
um and uh
you know make it as make it Mass
efficient and optimized for battery for
Batteries to say if that's done with the
aircraft uh you can get long-range
aircraft uh at around with with sales at
around 450 Watt hours per kilogram which
you can buy it right now actually it's
expensive but I think uh that price will
come down
so when we stack up all of these efforts
uh we end up with the numbers we shared
at the beginning of the presentation 30
terawatts 240 terawatt hours 10 trillion
dollars and you're you may be saying
like I need some context is this
feasible
spoiler alert it's entirely feasible
um just looking at it from a growth rate
growth rate perspective how much do we
need to grow the deployment of these
Technologies we're talking about only a
3X growth rate in solar and wind
deployment
um solar is already growing at a
Breakneck Pace as is wind this Gap is
going to be closed really quickly when
we look at the electric vehicles they
have to grow 11x well they grew 60 year
on year last year that growth rate is
also going to close pretty pretty darn
that Gap is going to close pretty
quickly as well and lastly storage
you know Tesla's energy storage business
has grown at 65 percent kagger since
2016. the global you know energy storage
business is is accelerating Pace as well
I mean all these gaps are going to close
especially as as this momentum of the
transition to sustainable energy
accelerates and of course our goal on
this page is 20 million EVS per year and
one terawatt hour of station missionary
storage per year basically as soon as we
can
um
and then what you know what about this
investment how do I have a reference
point on this investment you know Elon
mentioned it's 10 of you know uh one
year's world GDP another way of thinking
about it is how does it compare to what
we're investing like what we invested
last year in the fossil fuel
infrastructure
um and and it's 60 of that investment so
actually building this sustainable
energy uh economy is is less than
extending the fossil fuel economy from a
year-over-year investment basis so very
doable
um when we look towards does this fit on
the planet absolutely less than 0.2
percent of land as a reference point
um the total land area intensively
farmed today is 12 and a half percent of
all land so I mean you drive around you
see some Farms but you don't see them
everywhere this is this is an order of
magnitude more than order of magnitude
difference between farming and what
we're talking about for sustainable
energy land yeah it doesn't need to
displace Farmland of course you know
forests or jungle or any any kind of
ecological preserve it can be used in a
very sparsely populated desert regions
Barren areas areas that are just not
really fit for development or otherwise
used so yeah I mean 0.2 percent can fit
into a lot of places yeah it's it's
there's essentially no meaningful uh
ecological impact in fact transitioned
to a sustainable energy economy economy
would result in a substantial reduction
in current ecological impact it's a
great way to put it yeah
um and what about on the mineral
extraction side so this is a cartoon
that sort of gives you a sense for all
the ore and the like extracted minerals
that are coming out of the Earth every
year it's about 68 gigatons
um so each truck has to get 10. what
does this look like when we're in a
sustainable energy economy
looks like that
the fossil fuel extraction disappears we
replace it with the materials required
to fulfill the sustainable energy
economy actually reduces
now it's not to say that we don't need
to continue to explore you know bring
our Mining and refining for the sort of
specific materials for the sustainable
energy economy we do but the investment
in Mass flows are all very achievable
just looking at what is already
happening on the planet like this is
nothing out of scale of what has been
done and is already being done
um and then we calculate it on a sort of
you know element by element basis
the resources are there to support the
transition you know this is cumulative
demand to move into sustainable energy
economy Direction until 2050 relative to
USGS resources today you know we're not
breaking the Resource Bank
for any of these materials and then when
we look at what really happens as we
move forward
history teaches the more we look the
more we find what people think happens
is oh there's this many resources next
year there's going to be less because
we're going to extract them what
actually happens is as we uh extract
resources we we find more and you can
see on the right what has actually
occurred with the key materials to the
sustainable energy economy since 2000 as
a sustainable energy economy has been
growing and Tesla's been growing and all
the industries around us have been
growing the actual resource availability
has increased not decreased
yeah
this still seems to be quite a bit of
confusion about the about lithium
lithium is extremely common it's one of
the most common elements on Earth
um there is there's no country that has
Monopoly on lithium or even
close to it
um there's there's enough lithium uh or
in the United States to Electrify all of
Earth if the United States was the only
place producing lithium there's enough
domestic uh material to Electrify Earth
it's very common
um the the limit limiting factor uh is
the refining of the lithium into battery
grade lithium hydroxide or lithium
carbonate that's the actual limiting
factor and the same is true for these
other materials and and this is again
these are not like crazy Technologies
it's just the Investments need to be
made and the Investments they're not
gigantic they just need to happen right
um Nichols maybe the the of them all the
trickiest one to to solve but as we
showed with the graph there maybe you
need like 30 of the world's nickel no
nickel reserves so and the nickel
reserves have actually grown yes
thousands uh there is more yeah exactly
so
um and you only need nickel for uh
basically aircraft long-range boats
um and very long range cars or trucks uh
but the the vast majority of the heavy
lifting for electrification will be uh
iron-based uh cells and the Earth is
iron is actually literally the most
common elements on Earth so uh it looks
trivia point if you say like what is
Earth made of
by mass it is most it is made of iron
more than anything else and second
oxygen and then
uh everything else after that so
basically we're a muddy rust bowl is
what Earth is
um so an iron cathode is sort of you're
definitely not going to run out of iron
there's so much iron is insane
um
so that's it
yeah so yeah and ultimately you know
this resource uh extraction we go
through this effort we build these
batteries
um and then we recycle these batteries
so ultimately we're we're doing this to
build this sustainable energy economy
but the maintenance amount of of ore
that we require is is really an order of
magnitude or more less because of
recycling
um so in the end
a sustainable energy economy is within
our reach and we should accelerate it
yeah I mean so that this is really the
the main message of today
um and I really wanted today to be not
just about tells the investors who own
stock but uh really anyone who is an
investor in Earth
um and the what we're trying to convey
is a message of Hope and optimism
um and and hope optimism that is based
on on actual physics and and real
calculations not it's not wishful
thinking
uh Earth can and will move to a
sustainable energy economy and will do
so in your lifetime
thank you
yes
[Applause]
and uh I just want to welcome up uh Lars
and Franz to the stage
[Applause]
hi hi I'm Franz I have um lead design at
Tesla and I'm Lars I've been doing
vehicles with France for almost 13 years
now
so I joined Tesla in 2008 to vertically
integrate design into the company it
didn't exist before it was a pretty
small team it was tasked with designing
most beautiful innovative
and well-engineered vehicles on the
planet
no small task in 2008 there was not a
lot going on in the EV sector then
since then we focused on constant
Improvement and cost efficiency
Innovation things that you'll continue
to hear about today while continuing to
design the most desirable cars
today we produce cars differently than
we did 10 years ago but the end result
is always an exciting futuristic and
desirable set of vehicles
back then we only had a handful of
designers and Engineers like myself but
we had a great vision to radically
change transportation
so back
in 2008 we were designing Model S we
didn't have a factory
in fact we had a really small
engineering team and a tiny design team
but that allowed design to lead all the
conversations it let us innovate Forward
Thinking ideas like how do you fit seven
people into a sedan or how do you make
door handles disappear into the into the
doors or putting a huge touch screen
into the center of the the vehicle
something that had never been done
before
and then we won Motor train car of the
year yes and we want more to China Car
of the Year in 2013. our first our first
you know great award first car
um pretty good pretty good start kind of
a home run I think
um but that that whole process resulted
in a linear process that you see on the
screen we designed first then we
engineered and then we figured out how
to manufacture it yeah I mean I think
that's really important when we were
designing the car together we didn't
even know where we were going to build
it and so we came up with me even no
Lars winner that's true
uh we didn't so once we got Fremont we
were very fortunate and we figured out
the manufacturing solution sort of like
we were flying a plane and putting the
wings and building the engine at the
same time
so we knew we had to do better yeah we
knew he had to be better in order to
scale and as part of the master plan
that you've read
model 3 needed to be a smaller more
efficient and more affordable version of
Model S but had to be equally great it
adds up all the things that people loved
in their Model S or model X and but be
much more affordable
and so we we approached the process a
little bit differently than the first
time around now we had teams that we all
worked together so we were able to
combine design engineering and
Manufacturing process all at the same
time
but somewhere along the way we changed
the manufacturing process to be fully
automated
and so we leaned into this whole new way
of manufacturing a car but we had
already engineered it
so things didn't quite go as well as
planned it was an amazing product but it
landed Us in production hell
many of us who lived through that
carry those Battle Scars it was a great
idea but it wasn't the right timing like
Franz said automating something that we
designed to be built manually is super
hard and we have many many failed
examples of that at the Fremont Factory
that we ripped out but some of them
eventually still worked this is one I
actually worked on with small team of
Engineers it's still running today and
some of the engineers that came by said
we couldn't do it or no longer with the
company but it's running and is running
faster than ever
so we kind of self-imposed constraints
on the design when we were doing it to
be built manually and we really didn't
think about it but despite all that
model 3 is a best-selling EV ever yeah
and model Y which is derived from model
3 is about to pass that
but we knew we had to improve the
process further and with cyber truck
we designed a vehicle around a vision
that actually started with the
manufacturing process and in this case
the materials dictated the design
forming full heart stainless steel isn't
rocket science but it sure isn't easy
and it limited the way we could do it
yeah absolutely it really forced us to
think about designing something in a way
that you couldn't normally stamp panels
you couldn't form them in a traditional
way so you ended up with very linear
bending processes that are just not in
automotive kind of language of
manufacturing today but it actually
created a very efficient and process and
one of the most dynamic designs ever I
believe it's definitely something that's
going to change the road landscape
hopefully you guys saw it down there and
you experienced it it's definitely real
those are real trucks we're on our way
to build them but what that stainless
steel opportunity did for us it has let
us rethink the factory footprint we
don't Stamp Those that's a huge part of
it we don't even paint them so our
footprint got smaller and we started to
think about innovative ways to take
those constraints
and make great products
but that constraint didn't really change
the end result of the truck it's a super
Dynamic truck and it has all the
functionality you would expect out of
any of the other competitive trucks and
the best thing about it it's coming this
year
so ideally
after all that we would design engineer
manufacture and plan for automation
happening together it gives us the
opportunity to question requirements
this is something that is fundamentally
only available at Tesla the places I
used to work in the top manufacturing
companies in the world they don't sit
together one team nowhere I know has all
these teams together thinking about
these processes from the very beginning
in fact all of those engineering teams
manufacturing design automation they're
all in one work they all report to one
person we can't point fingers at each
other so we have to solve them together
which is the best way to innovate
a traditional way of making a vehicle is
this you stamp it you do build a body in
white you paint it and you do final
assembly and what's interesting is these
shops are dictated by the the
organizational structures that exist and
they're dictated by the boundaries that
exist in the factories that are laid out
if something goes wrong in final
assembly you block the whole line and
you end up with buffering in between
this is at the tail end
of its manufacturing optimization Henry
Ford first invented this assembly line
in 1922 it's been a hundred years and
it's really hard to make a change after
a hundred years and when you watch it
happen it's actually really silly to a
guy like me you take all these stamp
panels you put them together then you
put them in a framing station you build
a body that looks something like a car
you put the doors on
and then you paint them
once you get the color
you take the doors off
and then you start putting the interior
inside the car it comes in through the
openings that already exist I wish it
went in like this big piece like this
but there's actually people coming in
and out of the car there's awkward you
know movements then we lift the car up
we put stuff from underneath it we put
it down then we put the seats in the car
and finally we close it all out with
glass and we bring those doors that went
away for a trip and we put them back in
the car
most of the time we're doing this with a
big giant car and moving it and doing
really nothing to it at all
what's funny though in this kind of
whole process is that just recently
Toyota just called this an engineering
work of art
true
the model y
that that was humbling but at Tesla it's
not good enough if we're going to scale
the way we want to do we have to rethink
manufacturing again it's part of the
master plan we have to make another step
changing cost
we started this on model y when we made
these huge Giga castings and we deleted
hundreds of parts we simplified assembly
with the modelized structural battery
where we decided the floor should be a
part of the car the battery is the floor
we put the seats in the interior on the
battery and we bring it up through a big
open hole and we assemble it and this
allowed us to do things in parallel
fully rethinking the process and
reducing the final assembly line by
about 10 percent well and we thought
maybe we could do this other places yeah
I mean in a way
the the constraints become part of the
solution rather than a problem
so when you think about what I'm trying
to say I really want to hammer this home
when you have a car that's about five
meters long and you have people working
around it like we did in model 3. and we
change that to this process where we
take different parts of the car and we
can do more at the same time like we did
with the model y structural battery pack
what you see here is US doing that on
the front part of the vehicle or the
rear part of the vehicle
that means we can get more people
working on the car or robots working on
it at the same time that means we have
better operator density less time doing
nothing I call that space-time
efficiency it has nothing to do with
quantum mechanics we can have that
conversation later but we get 44 percent
more operator density which means more
work less time walking back to the
station 30 percent Improvement in
space-time efficiency and because we're
not building it in and out of the car
with those slow movements of those
robots I showed you from production hell
when we go to automate it it's going to
be a lot easier
in the end that will probably look
something like this where we balance
parallel and series Manufacturing in a
way where we only do things that are
necessary with a much shorter final line
blocking a lot less of the entire rest
of the factory so we can optimize
material flow using the best practices
and what that means it's going to look
something like this where we build all
the sides of the cars independently we
only paint what we need to and then we
assemble the parts of the car once and
only once we put them where they need to
go the interior is attached from a
bottom up or a top-down strategy so
there's more access for those robots and
people we aren't moving heavy objects
around and doing nothing to it and it
means we're doing more work on the car
more of the time
and then when we take it all of these
tested some assemblies and we put them
together we finally assemble the car
only one time putting the sides on with
all of their parts to a front and rear
that was already assembled carrying the
floor in with the seats and finally
boxing it out
with the doors one time just like cyber
truck
so in the end you get the same car
but it's not going to be a model y yeah
this is not this is a model y for
illustration not the next gen vehicle
in the end what does that mean to
increase the scale and Adoption of
electric vehicles on the orders of
magnitude that we just showed you we
have to make constraints part of the
solution
it leads us to greater than 40 percent
reduction in footprint which means we
can build factories faster with Lex
capex and more output per per unit
faster less capex more output per unit
dollar Zach's going to go into more
details on this later but it also means
through this Innovation and some of what
my other engineering colleagues are
going to talk to you about in the future
will reduce costs as much as 50 percent
this is the two for one concept you hear
me and Elon talking about on earnings
calls
yeah so I think our track record
approves that we can deliver the best
cars and we deliver the best cars in
spite of because of these constraints
and I'd love
to really show you what I mean and
unveil the next gen car but you're going
to have to trust me on that until a
later date
um just and I promise we'll always be
delivering exciting compelling and
desirable Vehicles like as we always
have we ever not we always do but what
else is Tesla known for
speed
so with that I want to bring on Colin
who's in charge of making our cars go
fast
thank you Lars thank you Franz my name
is Colin Campbell and I have the real
privilege of leading powertrain
engineering here at Tesla
we make the fastest cars that you can
buy for the money whether they're
electric or gas and the model S plaid
that we're looking at here it has more
than a thousand horsepower and pound per
pound the motors in that car are as
powerful as jet engines our cars are
super fun people absolutely love driving
in them
and the other thing that you probably
all know about our powertrains is that
they're efficient our Coast Go 25 to 30
percent further than other EVS in our
class for the same amount of efficiency
but at Tesla efficiency means more than
just reducing how much energy the cars
use it's about how we develop how we
manufacture how we refine and how we
scale the powertrain
now the model 3 and Y powertrain is a
great example of this broader meaning of
efficiency so since we launched it back
in 2017 we've continuously improved that
powertrain and the factory that builds
it so the Drive Unit the engine of the
car is 20 lighter for the same power we
use 25 percent less heavy Rare Earth
than when we started
and the fabric train the powertrain
Factory which is behind me today is 75
percent smaller and 65 percent cheaper
than the one that we originally built
and what I really want to emphasize is
that we did all of this without
compromise our cars are just as powerful
they go just as far
they cost the same or less and the
factories have the same output
so how did we do that
we did it by designing the entire
vehicle and the entire Factory together
as one company and this sets Tesla apart
we have small and highly capable teams
and to make a critical decision we can
have the battery cell chemists the
mechanical engineers the manufacturing
Engineers the supply chain team the
automation designers the software
programmers all in one room
working together in real time
and that allows us to make decisions
that are best for the whole car and to
make them really fast and that approach
is unlike traditional Automotive
Engineering which is really fractured
and if you were to go buy like a premium
German electric car the engineers who
designed the drive inverter in that car
they did not work for that car company
they worked for a contractor
and a Tesla we designed the entire car
and the factory that builds it
and I want to highlight a few examples
of what we've been able to do in-house
thanks to that unique approach
so
inside the charger of your Tesla are
transistor packages and that's at the
top of your screen here and every
electron that moves you down the road
flows through one of these packages
we designed our own custom package which
is what you're seeing here
and we can extract twice as much heat
out of that package as what we could buy
off the shelf and so what does that mean
it means that the silicone the silicon
carbide wafer that's inside those
packages can be much smaller and silicon
carbide it's an amazing semiconductor
but it's also expensive and it's really
hard to scale
so using less of it is a big win for us
and then on top of that orchestrating
all of these transistors and making them
switch in the right ways is
computationally extremely intensive it
used to require four microprocessors
which are shown here in the bottom left
we have developed our own custom
microprocessor
it's purpose built for high power
Electronics it's half the cost and it
does in just one the job of all those
four
and these are just two examples of many
that I could use to showcase our
expertise in high power electronics and
that expertise has allowed us to take
the cost of the Chargers that were in
our model S when we launched it in 2012
both the cost and the mass and cut both
of those in half
and even more important Power
Electronics are Central not just to our
cars
they're also Central to our
superchargers into our energy storage
products and Rebecca and Mike will be
talking more about that
so in addition to the work that we've
done in software and Hardware
we've also done a lot of work in-house
on software so this is the drive unit
for model three and one if we take a
cross section we see the stator in the
rotor and they're responsible for the
core function of the Drive Unit which is
converting electricity into motion
and our custom software lets us simulate
the rotating magnetic field that is
responsible for that conversion and
getting that simulation exactly right
it's Central to the cost the weight the
size and even the sound of the Drive
Unit
now you can buy software that will do
all of this but our tools are faster
and they're more accurate and that was
not easy to do
and that allows us to quickly iterate
through millions of possible Drive Unit
designs to find the best one
I want to highlight one more area
where Tesla really excels because we
integrate work that is often farmed out
so when you are making a new product
it's not enough to think about the
product itself you have to think about
how you're going to make it at scale
so Tesla our powertrain and our
powertrain manufacturing equipment is
both designed Under One Roof Engineers
who are designing the motor they are in
the same room as the engineers who are
designing the machine that's going to
put that motor together
and that collaboration pushes us from
day one
to design products that are not only
high performance but are really easy to
assemble
so
all of this expertise that we have in
the powertrain team and hardware and
software in manufacturing it's going to
have a major impact on our next platform
in our next Powertrain so silicon
carbide transistors that I mentioned
that are key component but expensive
we've figured out a way to use 75
percent less without compromising the
performance or the efficiency of the car
and of course we know the battery cell
Supply is one of the constraints on the
scalability of EVS right now
our new powertrain is compatible with
any battery chemistry
that will give us great flexibility in
battery sourcing
if we want to make EVS more accessible
to people they have to be cheaper
we've reduced the drive unit cost to
about a thousand dollars and we don't
think any other automaker is even close
to that number
finally the bigger a factor is the
longer it takes to build if we can build
the same number of cars from a smaller
Factory we are going to be able to scale
EV production faster
our next powertrain Factory is 50
smaller than the one that's behind me
today even though it has the same
capacity
all of these improvements I think are
going to be transformative for the
adoption of EBS and our ability to scale
them there's one more thing that I want
to highlight
so I talked about how we had reduced the
amount of rare earth in our powertrains
and as the world transitions to clean
energy the demand for Rare Earth is
really increasing dramatically and not
only is it going to be a little hard to
meet that demand
but mining that rare earth it has
environmental and health risks so we
want to do even better than this
we have designed our next Drive Unit
which uses a permanent magnet motor to
not use any rare earth materials at all
so how does all this fit into the master
plan
we can make lower cost products that are
still efficient and compelling and we
can make them at scale we're going to
use less of constrained Commodities
silicon carbide rarest
we're going to build them all in Compact
and high output factories that are easy
easy for us to build quickly
we're going to make that easy to scale
powertrains all the way up to the levels
that Drew and Elon mentioned at the
beginning
and this achievement like all of the
achievements that I mentioned today it's
only possible because of the incredible
people on our powertrain teams they are
absolutely committed to the cause of
sustainable energy and that is why we
can do what no other company can do
thank you
so next I'd like to welcome my
colleagues Pete Bannon David Lau
thanks Colin
thank you
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
Texas
pictured here is the low voltage system
of a Model S from 2012. this car was
primarily designed with vendor Source
controllers integrated by Tesla there
were over 300 volt low voltage devices
that Encompass everything from the
mundane like the light in the glove box
to the complicated like the infotainment
computer to the safety critical like the
airbags steer by wire and Brake by wire
the low voltage harness is built from
Individual wires cut to length crimped
and inserted into connectors a manual
process that is tedious error-prone and
doesn't scale well
going forward we want to reduce the size
and complexity of the harness and enable
automated Manufacturing
these wire harnesses introduce
extraordinary complications especially
in the early stages of development and
bring up of a vehicle because when we're
trying to bring up this entire system
and we see that it's not working
properly we don't know whether it's a
problem with the software with the
controller the processor any of the
endpoints in this entanglement of wires
and so we have to go and debug
everything all at once and Pete's going
to tell us about how we're going to make
it better
so we're going to talk briefly about a
few things that we've changed over the
years since the model S with the model 3
Tesla started designing an increasing
share of our controllers by emerging
controllers together
and we were able to simplify as the
design with a significant reduction in
wire count and weight going from s to 3
we reduce the wire harness by 17
kilograms compared to Model S and this
is a pretty big deal and just to put
that into context our VP of engineering
Lars will deliver a bottle of your
favorite Spirit to your desk if you
manage to save a kilogram of weight from
the car so this Improvement cost him
quite a lot
activity Skip One yeah the original
model 3 controllers were enhanced and
then and built into model y those
improved controllers were then moved
back into model 3 when we introduced the
heat pump at that point we had shared
controllers across both cars which
helped simplify our supply chain those
model 3 and Y controller designs were
then updated and enhanced for the new
versions of Model S and X that we
introduced in 2021
for cyber truck we are now designing 85
percent of the controllers on the car
for the next gen platform we're going to
finish the job and be designing 100 of
the controllers to give us full control
of the design and the supply chain at
the component level having full control
of the supply chain at the component
level has been critical to Tesla over
the last few years as the supply
constraints have hampered our ability to
build cars and with that control comes
control over all the software which
enables us to develop features and
functionality that we never even dreamed
of at the time we designed the hardware
so that's why you see software in your
car is getting better and better over
time in ways that we didn't even think
of when we designed the hardware in the
first place yeah Sentry mode is one of
my favorite last minute favorites
with the internship introduction of
model 3 in 2017 we deleted relays and
fuses from the car in favor of e-fuses
e-fuses replace moving Parts with
solid-state transistors they provide
fine-grained control of the power system
to software and allow software to do
Advanced things like load shedding in
the car under adverse conditions efuses
also allow for software controlled
retries for transient faults and they
all allow for detailed monitoring of the
power system over time
yeah well the theme you hear a lot about
today is software controlled hardware
and when I think about that in my team
software controlled Hardware is
fundamentally about being able to
sidestep what otherwise would have been
static trade-offs between one attribute
or another in a piece of Hardware we are
able with software to instill
intelligence context awareness and
context-specific behavior into what
otherwise would have been a piece of
Hardware that had to get optimized for
one type of scenario
we get more of everything in 2022 we
completed the transition and lead acid
batteries to lithium-ion batteries and
and which use a new tool-less connector
we expect Lithium-ion batteries to last
for the life of the car so we don't
expect anyone to wake up to a dead
battery ever again this eliminates a
major source of failures for our car and
the toolist connector makes it easier to
service the car and it also includes a
software feature to allow
validation that the connector has been
properly installed at the end of a
service event which removes another
source of failures in our cars obviously
the mass and volume savings are also
significant which is super helpful
um at Tesla we're always trying to
improve every single component in the
car and a nice example of that is the
15-inch display that was originally
shipped in the 2017 model 3. over time
the cost of the display has gone down 24
percent we've been able to reduce the
weight by 12 and we've reduced the power
by 33 percent at the same time we've
increased the brightness of the display
by 50 and improve the color accuracy so
this is one of our favorite things that
Tesla does make a component cheaper and
better
at Tesla the drive to improve efficiency
in the car is never ending I think of it
as like peeling a carrot you just take a
swipe at it a little bit falls off
doesn't really make much of a difference
but if you just keep at it over time it
accumulates into a pretty significant
Improvement
one of the changes that we're looking to
make right now is to change something
that's been steady for the last 60 years
12 volts
12 votes has been as I said for 60 years
the demand for power in the car has been
steadily increasing to the point where
we now have to have pretty large wires
to drive over 200 amps of current around
the car which increases the mass and
costs with cyber truck and all future
Tesla platforms we will be moving to 48
volts this reduces the current needed by
a factor of four and since power loss in
the harness is resistance times the
square of the current a 4X reduction and
current leads to a 16x reduction in lost
power while Distributing energy in the
car
uh that allows for smaller wires smaller
e-fuses and smaller controllers it also
allows us to make those heat sinks
smaller or in many cases remove it
completely all benefiting the car in
terms of mass and weight 48 volts is the
future for a low voltage design at Tesla
and likely the rest of the industry in
due course we welcome and encourage
other oems and the entire supplier
Network to join us on this Evolution you
bet
huh the number of wires in the car is
driven by the number of endpoints that
need to be powered and controlled in the
past centralized control has led for
wires spanning the entire car
for cyber Truck design we have moved to
a local controller where the wire is
connected to the nearest controller and
those controllers are connected over
ethernet
wires are routed to the nearest
controller where the data is converted
into a network packet for transition
transmission to the correct location on
the car to be effective the network must
be reliable have low latency and low
Jitter and these are all attributes that
we've been able to achieve with the
current design
the design has delimited most of the
crossword car wires in cyber truck and
with the next gen platform we're going
to finish the job and eliminate all of
them
the some Consolidated vehicle Network
allows us also to make a whole lot more
Dynamic changes on the fly to how
components in the vehicle talk to each
other rather than the traditional
approach of separate can buses that are
spread throughout the vehicle yeah and
once did hardware and one of the nice
things is that you can see the entire
vehicle through a single connection
which wasn't possible in the past for
debug
for the next gen platform we're looking
to optimize the controller design across
the entire car and across all of the
organizations not just for a given
subsystem simplifying the wire harness
will enable automation 48 volts will
allow us to reduce the size
mass and cost of the low voltage system
and is one of the key things to enabling
us to scale the production of the low
voltage systems to for the master plan
3.
David
cool
so I joined Tesla in 2012 and even in
those very early days of the model S we
already had the ability to update
software over the air in all the
controllers throughout the entire
vehicle at the time when other cars were
just starting to update software in only
their infotainment units
and furthermore we've had sophisticated
anonymized data logging and Telemetry
capabilities that allow us to understand
how the fleet is doing what customers
are doing with it and how it's
responding in the field to that usage
these two capabilities combined
OTA updates and Data Insights give us
the ability to iterate quickly on our
software and to maximize the amount that
we learn and and proceed and and the
progress that we make in every one of
those iterations
we've used these capabilities to form
countless design decisions in both
software and Hardware
yeah one example is that we were able to
Monitor and track the use of the sunroof
in our cars and found that our customers
never use their sunroof so we made an
easy decision to remove it very barely
yeah we haven't had sunroofs for a while
um
as another example we are able to use
our Collision data to design our crash
safety systems for what happens in the
real world far beyond what regulatory
and consumer ratings tests prescribe
and then furthermore we're able to use
that data to recreate in simulation all
of those crashes every single time we
make a change to the vehicle's design or
to the software that controls the
airbags and other restraint systems
here on this graph the gray dots that
show up first are specific crash tests
that are prescribed by Regulatory and
consumer ratings agencies throughout the
whole world
and the rest of the color that fills in
around and on top of it those represent
the crashes that we've seen happen in
the real world
those are what we design for and what we
test to
right and last year this data was used
to change the algorithm for seat belt
tensioning to reduce injuries in the
field which was Otay to all of our cars
here are a few statistics that
demonstrate how staggeringly quickly we
gain new insights from the anonymized
data that we've received from the fleet
every day every day 123 million miles
driven 1.9 million charge sessions and
those rates are only increasing as we
deliver more and more cars into the
world
as another example we've analyzed
patterns in the way the fleet drives and
charges to optimally size battery packs
for our next Generations of vehicles and
you'll hear lots of other examples
throughout the rest of the day about how
we're using data to inform decisions in
the product and in manufacturing
so you've heard a lot from Pete calling
others about how important vertical
integration is for us and Hardware but
it's especially important for us in
software and this is extremely difficult
from the way the rest of the traditional
automotive supply chain is set up
in most situations all the controllers
in the car are delivered by different
tier one suppliers whose software is
written by tier 2 suppliers who Farm
some of that software out to different
tier 3 suppliers and so on and so on
making a change that spans multiple
components takes months of coordination
before any work can even start
and furthermore integration of software
and the server side with what's
happening in our vehicles has always
been a core part of our DNA enables us
to do things that nobody else can
most Engineers think about the vehicle
as a complete Consolidated fully
contained system but in the software
team we think about the system as
including the vehicle as well as all of
our back-end server-side applications
and infrastructure and the resultant
feedback loop from the entire fleet that
informs all the decisions we make as an
engineering team
for example we recently released a
feature in model snx that automatically
predictively adjusts and raises the
suspension for ride Comfort before the
car hits a section of rough road
we do that by leveraging the fleet to
generate a map of Road roughness
everywhere our cars drive
sounds pretty simple but requires
coordination of software across a number
of different components inside and
outside of the car
the restraint control module whose
inertial measurement unit senses the
road roughness
the autopilot computer whose GPS module
and localizer figure out where the car
is in the world
our navigation server which Aggregates
the anonymized Telemetry from the fleet
and annotates our map with things like
updated speed limits Lane topology and
now Road roughness
the onboard navigation engine which
looks ahead of the route that the car is
traveling on and determines whether
things are about to get rough
and finally the air suspension
controller which takes all of those
factors into account and decides
continuously whether it is appropriate
to adjust the suspension for ride
comfort
and before we release this feature to
the world we sent prototype versions of
it to the entire fleet that ran
passively in the background sending us
Anonymous data about every time it would
have engaged which taught us exactly how
it was going to behave in the wild in
every environment in every circumstance
yeah being able to test new algorithms
in the background without an impact in
the car is really critical ability for
us especially for safety critical things
like automatic emergency braking and
we've used it to iterate on early
versions of our stability control
algorithms which were introduced to the
entire model 3 Fleet in 2017 with
extreme extremely high confidence even
on a very foundational and safety
critical function
okay
talk a lot about how we leverage our
software systems to iterate quickly on
the customer facing product but what I
haven't talked about and what we haven't
said much about publicly in general is
how we leverage these capabilities in
our own internal operations
so for example in the early days of
manufacturing Model S we very quickly
realized that there are a lot of
different ways you could misassemble a
car
you could forget to plug in a wire you
could not fully set a connector you
could pull apart from the wrong bin
so when we designed our manufacturing
processes for model 3 and all of our
other vehicles going forward we took a
page from the software Playbook which
says
test early and test often
and we applied that Mantra to every
single car that we build at every step
of the assembly line
so now when a production associate plugs
something into the car the central car
computer sees that connection confirms
that it's the correct part for the type
of car that's supposed to be built
installs a software update if necessary
checks configurations and calibrations
and runs a barrage of tests on that
thing and all the other things that are
connected to it and if it finds an
anomaly that can't be fixed purely with
software it throws an alert immediately
that is displayed prominently on the
vehicle's display as well as sent to
back-end command and control systems so
that a human can come over and fix the
problem before the rest of the car gets
built on top of it
and we're taking a similar approach in
service through a combination of
on-board vehicle diagnostics natural
language processing applied to customer
narratives when a customer schedules a
service appointment and a suite of
internally developed tools we are
successfully diagnosing scheduling and
ordering parts for over 33 percent of
customer concerns and service
yep and we also use testers built around
our own controllers to test
sub-assemblies before they get to the
car which will be even more important as
we go to lars's unboxed assembly
strategy 100 we'll know with extremely
high confidence that before those boxes
get put together
that they're that they are assembled
they themselves are assembled correctly
okay
other events about all the awesome
things that are autopilot and AI teams
are doing to make the car drive itself
bringing us into the future of autonomy
but we've also been thinking for years
about all of the other pieces that we
are going to need to manage a network of
autonomous vehicles
a lot of this has been happening behind
the scenes in the form of platform level
functionality that we'll leverage later
but you've seen some of its surface
already in terms of features that our
customers and our internal operations
teams can benefit from
like in 2021 we built on top of our
mobile app phone key and gave our
customers the ability to share their car
with anyone by sending them an
invitation in a text message or an email
last year we introduced profile
synchronization which synchronizes your
seat steering and mirror positions as
well as your settings media favorites
and stored navigation locations across
all vehicles in your account
internally we have an app that allows
our Personnel in engineering
manufacturing delivery and Logistics to
view locate and drive all tesla-owned
vehicles at their site
and when customers bring their car into
service when they receive a Tesla's own
service loaner vehicle we are starting
at some locations to automatically add
that vehicle to the customer's mobile
app account so that combined with Cloud
synchronized profiles and phonekey it's
a completely seamless experience as soon
as the customer walks up to that loaner
it behaves and feels exactly like their
own car
and all this is built on top of
end-to-end encryption and
cryptographically signed commands
so that customer data remains private
and obscure and the fleet only trusts
commands from authorized parties
so that's a bit of a preview of all the
pieces that we're building looking ahead
to our future of autonomous fleets
synchronization permissions management
security and privacy
and that has been a whirlwind tour
through some of the things that we're
doing behind the scenes to enable the
efficiency cost reduction and speed that
we are going to need for their next
phase of growth and for the next phase
of the master plan
and so now to tell us about the latest
in full self-driving
I'd like to introduce Ashok
[Applause]
thanks David and Pete hey everyone my
name is Asha kaliswami I work on
autopilot and cell driving at Tesla I
joined Tesla back in 2014 so I've been
working on this problem for almost nine
years now
yeah some of you might be wondering hey
what's the self-driving got to do with
the plan to a sustainable future
but it's actually a critical part of
this plan and here's why
currently when the car is not being used
it is sitting idly in parking lots not
doing anything
but when autonomy is truly unlocked
this car instead of being idle can go
serve other customers
this fundamentally now reduces the
need to scale manufacturing to extreme
levels because each car is being used
way more
but this is no trivial problem building
is scalable self-driving system is I
think one of the hardest real world a
problems out there right now
nonetheless
we at Tesla have made significant
strides in making
one of the most General systems at
solving this problem
there are three main parts to get right
to build a scalable problem
first is the architecture
the architecture of the AI system second
is the data and third
is the compute we'll start with the
architecture
at Tesla we are betting on AI machine
learning neural networks to help us
build a general vision and planning
system
in the early days we used to have single
camera single frame neural networks that
produce some outputs these facets
together in some post processing steps
for the planner but this was very
brittle and was not leading to great
success so what we did in the last few
years is transition most offer stack
into this multi-camera video neural
networks
these neural networks take in the live
feed from the car in real time of the
eight cameras in the car
and produce a single unified 3D output
space
there are many tasks that we produce
such as the presence of obstacles then
motion Lanes roads traffic lights what
have you
and this is one example output that
you're seeing here this is from our
occupancy Network that predicts the
positions of obstacles and then motion
you can see that it precisely captures
the swervy violent motion of this truck
next to us and this helps the planning
system to avoid a collision with this
object
some of the tasks such as Lane
connectivity are more complicated to
model using native methods in computer
vision
so we don't stop at the computer vision
techniques but we reach out to
techniques in other areas such as
language modeling reinforcement learning
to model this task this is similar these
these networks use similar techniques
such as Transformers attention modules
Auto regressive modeling of tokens
similar to what large longest models
like chat GPT do out there
with such an end-to-end system of
solving perception we have really
removed the brittle post processing
steps and produce high quality outputs
for the planning system
even the planning system is not struck
in the old ways it is now starting to
use more and more AI systems to solve
this problem
the neural neural network based planners
are needed especially in complicated
urban planning when there's a lot of
other objects interacting with us
this is for example an intersection
where we have to turn left while leading
to Crossing objects and to the
pedestrians crossing the road we have to
do this both safely and smoothly while
respecting everyone's right-of-way and
preferences
if this was done naively each
configuration would take 10 milliseconds
of compute and are easily easily
thousands of configurations to reason
about
this would not be feasible using
traditional compute but using AI we have
packaged all of this into a 50
millisecond compute budget so it can run
in real time
the second big piece of this puzzle is
the data this is where Tesla has a
unique Advantage because it can tap into
the feed and tap into the fleet to
access the exact data that can fix the
problems
but raw data is not sufficient
we in order to train these Networks you
need label data you need labels to
supervise the networks
and if you only depended on the human
labelers this data would be too tiny to
train these large multi-camera video
modules we need a lot lots and lots of
data to train these Networks
hence
we have built a sophisticated Auto
labeling pipeline
that collects data from the fleet
runs computational algorithms in our
data center and then produces the labels
to train these Networks
here you are seeing a 3D reconstruction
that is happening by collecting various
clips from different cars in the fleet
and assembling them all of them together
into a single unified representation of
the world around the car you can see all
the lanes the road boundaries curb
crosswalks even the text on the road
being accurately reconstructed by these
algorithms
we don't have to stop at this kind of
reconstruction
once we have this base reconstruction we
can build various simulations on top of
it to produce an infinite variety of
data to train for all the corner cases
we have a capable simulator that can
synthesize adversarial weather lighting
conditions and even the motion of other
objects to test all the corner cases
that might even be rare in the real
world
here's an example of why this data is
critical and how we can solve problems
using data
so back in the days
for example in this case we had some
false breaking where we thought this car
that's actually parked there was going
to move into our path and hence we were
precautiously breaking
but it is unnecessary because the car is
truly parked
so how can we solve this what we did was
we mined the fleet for similar cases
where they call it false breaking due to
some park car
we added 14 000 videos to our training
set and then once we train the networks
again with this new data it now
correctly understands that okay there is
no driver in this car hence it must be
part so then there is no need to break
and this is a systematic way to solve
problems on the chart on the right side
you can see that every time we add data
the performance improves and then we can
do this for every kind of task that we
have in our system
and this is what we call as data engine
we identify challenging cases such as
the one you saw earlier and there could
be other different types of challenging
cases too we mine the fleet for such
data
put it through our Auto labeling system
and produce the labels add it to the
training set
and once you have the newly trained
models we deployed them to the Feet
Fleet
if we rinse and repeat this process
everything gets better and better
the final critical piece is the compute
in order to train these large models in
a reasonable amount of time you need
lots of compute in addition compute is
also required to produce the labels
automatically this is just compute you
know data centers in addition we also
have high
compute computers in the car which can
run up to like 150 terabs of compute
on the back end we have a 14 000 GPU
cluster and roughly 30 is used for auto
labeling and the remaining 70 is used
for training
we also have a 30 petabyte of video
cache and this is growing to 200
petabytes all of this is going to
significantly increase when we once we
bring Dojo which is our training
computer on board into this
just to give a reference just the
occupancy networks that you saw earlier
use 1.4 billion frames to train these
Networks
we have already shipped our FSD beta
software to pretty much everyone that
has bought it in United States and
Canada
this amounts to roughly 400 000
customers who can turn it on anywhere
and then the car would attempt to drive
to the destination is still supervised
uh but it can already handle turns
stopper traffic lights yield with other
objects and generally get to the
destination
we have observed that people who use FSD
are already five to six x safer than the
US national average
like you mentioned earlier the solution
to scalable FSD is getting the a
architecture the data and the compute
just right and we have assembled a
world-class team to execute on this
we are pushing the frontier on this on
these three items and as we improve the
safety and the reliability and the
comfort of a system we can then unlock
driverless operations which then makes
the car be used way more than what it's
used right now
that I'd like to introduce uh Elon back
on stage to give some more updates
[Applause]
yes
it's kind of weird seeing the arms and
legs just separate
we have a whole lab full of arms and
legs
worth bearing in mind that when we did
AI day
uh this version of Optimus didn't work
for walk at all
so the rate of improvement here I think
is is quite significant
it's obviously not doing parkour
but I
it is walking around and we have
multiple multiple uh
copies I suppose of Optimus
the thing that's
I think Tesla brings the table
that others don't have is that
we have
we have the real world AI we're the most
advanced in real world AI so the same AI
that
drives the car
which you can think of the car really is
a robot on Wheels and this is a robot on
legs
so as we solve real world Ai and I don't
think there's any I don't think there's
anyone even close to Tesla on solving
real world AI
that same computer and software
goes into Optimus
so it's all that helpful to have a
humanoid robot if you have to program
every individual action it needs to be
able to
walk around autonomously and solve tasks
you should be able to instruct it in
simple things by showing visually what
you're what what the robot needs to do
or just telling it what to do so
um so I think that's a key advantage
that we have and then we also are good
at designing things for manufacturing
and then manufacturing itself so the the
actuators in Optimus are all custom
designed Tesla actuators
so we designed the the light the
electric motor of the gearbox the Power
Electronics obviously the battery pack
and everything else that goes into
Optimus
we're actually quite we were quite
surprised to find how little
was available off the shelf because
there's a lot of a vast number of
electric motors
um gearboxes and whatnot that are
available in the world and we found none
of them were useful in a humanoid robot
literally none
so
you have to Custom Design the
actuators
for a human right robot
and so the same team that designed the
groundbreaking
electric motors that are in the say the
model S plaid designed the actuators in
the robot
um
so I mean for practical purposes what
this means is that we should be able to
bring an actual product to Market at
scale that is useful
um
far faster than anyone else
and you know assuming the things I'm
saying are true or at least you put it I
think they are true you can just it's
just a question of the timing
um
you start getting into interesting
questions of like what's the ratio of
humans to humanoid robots
I think it might be greater than one to
one
you know because you could you could
sort of see a use a home use for robots
certainly industrial uses for robots uh
humanoid robots
um I think I think we might exceed a
one-to-one ratio of humanoid robots to
humans
it's not even clear what an economy
means at that point you know since an
economy is output per person times
persons but if output is much higher and
there's no limit on Persons then
what's the actual limit on the economy
you know
we're still pretty far from Carter Chef
scales here but uh
we're getting there
so anyway uh
it's a
probably the least understood or
appreciated part of what we're doing at
Tesla but will probably be worth
significantly more than the uh the car
side of things long term
so charge I think Rebecca's next or
talking about charging
charge
[Applause]
thanks
hi there my name is Rebecca tanucci and
I lead our charging infrastructure teams
here at Tesla
and at Tesla charging we have understood
since day one that a great charging
experience is the linchpin to electric
vehicle adoption and that understanding
has meant that we've always taken a
holistic approach to charging that's a
word that you've heard a lot here today
but what it means for charging is that
we've considered every use case we think
a lot about what it means to charge at
home even if that home is an apartment
or condo and we spend a lot of time
thinking about what does it mean to
charge away from home including if
that's for daily commuting or if you're
going on a road trip
and this holistic approach has led to
some pretty incredible results in 2022
we provided nine terawatt hours of
charging across our various charging
methods over 50 percent of that was
supplied via convenient AC home charging
and when our customers are away from
home they can visit one of our 80 000
charging points that includes 40 000 of
our beloved superchargers
now getting here has meant that we've
spent 10 years building charging
infrastructure when basically no one
else in the industry would do it and
while we certainly have a lot of areas
that we want to improve those 10 years
have afforded us the opportunity to get
pretty good at charging
first we have the industry's lowest
deployment cost our costs are often 20
if not 70 percent lower than
Alternatives and that goes for both our
supercharging hardware and deployments
and our AC charging product lines
a lot of reasons that we're able to
achieve this you've heard a lot of them
here today we're vertically integrated
we manufacture and engineer all of our
own charging equipment we share
components across our different product
lines and on the supercharger side we
also install and operate all of our own
sites and that's led us to be pretty
obsessed with finding new ways to
innovate around installation
as an example we have recently extended
our excellence in manufacturing to how
we build supercharger sites we are
pre-building four post supercharger
units at our Factory and Giga at our
Factory in New York we load them on a
truck we truck them to site and then we
crane them into position this method
saves us 15 on our deployment costs and
we can install a site in a matter of
days
once we install a site we also operate
it really efficiently over the last few
years we've been able to cut our per
kilowatt hour cost by 40 percent again a
lot of reasons for this but one at the
top of the list is we focused on
increasing our site utilization site
utilization is just how many sessions or
kilowatt hours can we push through a
site or a post and basically doing that
allows us to spread our costs over more
sessions thus lower cost per kilowatt
hour but of course that's easier said
than done because when we push up site
efficiency of course the risk is that we
we have a poor customer experience we
have wait time at our sites
this is where trip planner comes in trip
planners are in vehicle routing or
navigation system
other electric vehicle manufacturers
well some of them have vehicle side data
other infrastructure providers have site
data but at Tesla we have both and what
that allows us to do is to use trip
planner to Route Vehicles towards
available sites and away from congested
sites so we can balance our utilization
without risking wait time and the
results speak for themselves over the
last few years we've been able to drive
up site utilization by 30 percent that
means lower per kilowatt hour cost while
also cutting our wait time in half
and we think this can get even better
today we're feeding trip planner with
real-time site information and
information about Vehicles currently at
sites going forward we'll be moving that
to projecting site occupancy based on
the understanding of what vehicles are
currently routing to those sites and
ultimately our vision for trip planner
is that it's the air traffic controller
for electric vehicle charging across all
infrastructure on a global basis
and the last thing we focused on to get
here is quicker charge times we're
really proud of what we've been able to
accomplish here we've shaved off 30
percent of our charge time average
supercharging site time visit time over
the last few years this has taken
improvements on the hardware side with
our software on our vehicles and on our
infrastructure and we're really excited
to continue pushing this trend down
looking forward the job does not get any
easier as you heard earlier we aspire to
a fully electrified Global Fleet that
Fleet from an industry standpoint needs
nine petawatt hours of charging on an
annual basis and while Tesla charging
certainly doesn't have to supply all of
that it does require that for our part
we have a few new focuses in order to
scale
first if you want a fully electrified
Global Fleet all of those vehicles have
to have a great and reliable charging
experience so as many of you know
recently we have started opening opening
up our networks on a global basis over
50 percent of our superchargers in
Europe are currently open to other
electric vehicles we've also opened up
in Asia Pacific with our first sites in
Australia and just yesterday we opened
our first 10 supercharger sites here in
North America in the US to other
electric vehicles
we've also invested a lot to be able to
make this a really easy experience for
our new customers all you have to do is
sign into our Tesla app to unlock a post
and start charging we've also on
physical site changes we've also added
Hardware to our sites they're called
Magic docs and basically that is
installed in areas where we have
different charging standards and they
allow for other electric vehicles to
come to our site without having to bring
their own adapters or Hardware
we've also just started installing our
fourth generation supercharger posts
those are being installed in Europe
first and while it's not a big mention
not a big thing to mention they do have
longer charging cables so that we can
more easily reach the charge ports of
different vehicles
the second thing we need to make sure we
do when we talk about scaling all of
this charging infrastructure is we need
to make sure that it's powered from
renewable sources we're very proud that
over the last two years we've procured
enough renewable energy to offset the
amount of charging we've provided to
customers but as we look forward and we
talk about this fully electrified Fleet
on a global basis we really want to make
sure that the demand for charging more
closely follows when renewable sources
are available now this chart is on an
aggregate basis for the us and it varies
based on what your renewable generation
sources are locally but basically what
this shows is we want to kind of move
that charging curve and for solar and
wind in this example it means more
daytime charging and we think the best
way to go towards daytime charging is to
install into install AC charging that is
convenient and low cost everywhere
vehicles are typically parked throughout
the day so that's really the plan while
supercharged charging and home charging
definitely stay a big part of the puzzle
our teams are currently scaling to
install AC charging everywhere Vehicles
charge during the day so we can power
them from renewable sources
so summing it up while we've spent 10
years installing infrastructure that is
low cost it's efficient and it provides
a great customer experience we're really
just getting started when we talk about
supporting master plan part three we've
got a scale capacity on an industry-wide
basis to nine petawatt hours on an
annual basis we've got to open up to
non-teslas and make the charging
experience for everybody really great
and we've got to power all this via
renewable sources
and one more thing yes we've got a scale
we've got to scale our infrastructure
and yes we want to power it via
renewable sources but we're Tesla so we
also want to make sure that we're
continuing to focus on providing really
incredible charging experiences
with that I want to welcome up our
leaders of supply chain Rashon and Karn
to talk a little bit about that topic
[Applause]
thanks Rebecca
hi my name is Karen and my team leads uh
supply chain for electronics powertrain
and battery or Tesla and we've also got
responsibility for indirect purchasing
construction procurement and warehousing
and distribution
hi my name is Roshan I've been with
Tesla for over 14 years
my team manages
vehicle Commodities solar Logistics
planning and Capital Equipment 10 years
forgot that
um so today we wanted to provide you a
quick overview of Tesla supply chain and
what really separates us from the
typical automotive supply chain as
you've seen in presentations prior from
Pete and Drew and some others Tesla
designs a lot of the sub components that
go into our vehicles so we're not buying
things that are off the shelf from
suppliers so supply chain is not purely
a commercial relationship as it is in
most other companies we actually have an
arm within supply chain called supplier
industrialization engineering and the
burden of taking a a drawing a design
from concept and trying to get into
thousands of products produced at the
right cost and at the right yield Falls
for this group of course they work very
closely with design engineering but
really the level of detail that our
engineers get involved in terms of
building the capability of the suppliers
is is pretty detailed so you know once
we get a new part naturally with
electric vehicles a lot of the supply
chain doesn't exist our Engineers would
basically take the drawing turn it into
the manufacturing concept do the
equipment selection and physically go to
the supplier and stay there for weeks or
months however long it takes to
basically do the line bring up once the
line is brought up and we're hitting the
the right rate the right quality at the
right yield then we work on things like
Automation and Ill Improvement and and
those types of activities
so there's there's a big group of
mechanical electrical industrial you
name it Engineers within supply chain
and it's their responsibility to take
care of this now this is a huge
strategic Advantage because we manage
every detail of our supply chain because
we're so integrated with our partners
that we know about issues before they
happen it's almost live we've got
dashboards we've got connections and
across the 10 you know ten thousand or
so factories across the world that are
managed making our components we have a
pretty good view of the health of those
suppliers and this has been a key asset
and and how we've been able to kind of
manage things uh through a lot of
different issues over the past couple of
years so
um
you know supply chain is a game of
perfection Perfection is a passing grade
it's like a you know if one part doesn't
show up that line goes down and our CEO
finds out about it in less than 20
minutes and Tesla is very different than
Apple they Outsource manufacturing we do
it in-house so supply chain is kind of
right in the middle uh and and
Perfection is is increasingly Elusive
and very expensive uh if you kind of
look at uh all the the the the the
issues we've had to encounter over the
past year and and today we're just going
to talk about how we got through the
past and then what are we going to do
going forward and how are we going to
get there
so let me draw your attention to this
slide on the left you'll see a portfolio
our existing portfolio of products right
at the type you've got the snx platform
in the middle you've got three and Y I
think everyone's more than familiar with
with those and then the Tesla energy
platform which is a very high rate of
growth for us
and you forget the solar and
supercharger and so learn supercharger
thank you Roshan and you'll see a
reduction uh in so and and then we
basically got the tier one and tier two
parts this might be boring but a tier
one supplier is any supplier that builds
and supplies Parts directly for
consumption in our five factories and
our tr2 supplier basically does the same
thing for a tier one supplier so they
are the supplier to our supplier and
depending on the supply chain of any one
of these products this can actually go
down to the tier six levels for example
if you're talking about the battery cell
we really get involved with the minds of
like where we're procuring the lithium
the Cobalt and all that sort of stuff
because we're procuring such high
volumes of it so you'll see a reduction
in the number of Parts on the snx
platform uh to the 3ny platform and and
this is because of the great work our
design Engineers have done of making the
car simpler and easier to manufacture in
parallel we actually had a similar
strategy and supply chain we had cast a
wide net to a lot of supplies for the
snx platform there was a lot of
suppliers that we invited to partner
with us and we used that
platform as sort of a filter to see
which suppliers have the technical
financial and cultural capabilities to
match us right who like who do we invite
to the party when we really scale things
up and we you know we've really
dramatically reduced the number of
suppliers that we were dealing with for
the 3ny platform and this is an approach
we'll continue to do for future
platforms as they come along that are
even more high volume so this this has
really been an approach it's made things
uh a lot easier and it you know we we
could we could figure out the suppliers
that were capable of of moving at our
pace and and then the ones that didn't
have the desire to order the capability
to you need both design capability
um secondly the complexity on the tier 2
level is is very high right these are
the suppliers to our suppliers and there
are a lot of components so think about
silicon think about resistors capacitors
diodes uh all the little assemblies raw
materials raw materials that's even
further down yeah but all these little
sub-assemblies that have to come into
Tesla the the complexity is immense so
even though at the tier one level we're
talking about 8 000 Parts total it seems
like a lot but it's not a lot the
management of the tier 2 is really where
we Excel and I'd like to illustrate that
with an example
meet the car computer
very innocent sounding name and it's
anything but this is an absolute monster
to manage so I think you've all seen the
picture on the left of the autopilot
board that's the top of the autopilot
board the autopilot board also has a
bottom and the bottom is populated
heavily with components on the other
side of the heatsink you've got the MCU
the multimedia cluster board this board
is equally complex it's also
double-sided eight layered and these
boards these computers run so hot at
Peak operation that they have to be
liquid liquid cooled through a heat sink
so this assembly requires taking those
two boards and then bonding them to a
heat sink that's hermetically sealed as
an assembly of course flashing the
software and all that sort of stuff and
then that's one part number that comes
to Tesla so this is an example of one
tier one part number that's a very
complex assembly to manage at the tier 2
level and
there's more than seven thousand
components here there's a you know as we
stand here a components being assembled
onto a car computer every 1.4
milliseconds the line that builds this
computer is the length of a football
field so it's it's quite complicated and
initially when we first started building
this board due to the complexity of it
we had to rely heavily on labor but once
we dialed in the quality the rates and
the yield we started focusing on making
this more efficient the only way to
control cost is by removing labor the
first step is removing labor the second
step is fully automating the third step
is turning off the lights and letting
the factory run ideally and that's going
to be the goal for us here so 95 but our
work is not done we're going to be going
a lot further than this
so this illustrates the point that
a part is not a part A Part has a lot of
complexity underneath it supply chain is
a game of multiple tiers and and what's
made us successful is our involvement in
all the details with our supplier
Engineers uh that are Tesla employees
they're Tesla Supply Engineers so
they're like on our payroll that go and
ramp up these capabilities that are
suppliers and then just managing each
and every attribute of it you know seven
thousand a day through the chip shortage
through the pandemic through all the
other stuff that we had to deal with was
was very difficult to manage but because
we had all the details we were able to
pull this off
um of course supply chain is not just
about Parts it's also about logistics
and a lot of other things so hand it off
to Roshan for sharing some stats
yeah so talk about inboard complexity
just over the coast course of just last
year we moved about 16 million pallets
from our suppliers to our factories just
to visualize that if you put those
pallets side by side it could cover the
half the circumference of the Earth
and talk about again the tier two
complexity
over 1 billion electronic components get
moved every week to support the
production that current NT manages this
is right now one billion components a
week right 52 billion this is going to
go up by the way and and on top of that
we also have the responsibility to make
sure the right component is supplied to
the right service location to support
the growing Fleet of our vehicles and we
have about 685 service centers that
these components need to show up just in
time
um and then we've also been uh as as uh
as a result of pandemic and even before
that we're working working on Dual
sourcing and triple sourcing some of our
critical components as a result of it we
have suppliers around 45 countries in
the world yeah approach really has been
to bring the manufacturing of sub
components closer to the point of
consumption it makes the supply chain
more green because you're not burning
diesel moving stuff around and it also
gives us the security supply of having
multiple sources in case one factor gets
taken offline and that's how we got
through pandemic also
um
so last three years were incredibly hard
and I used to look a lot younger
pre-covered
but on a serious note
pandemic really changed the game of
Supply Chain management
we were just not being a regular supply
chain person we're rolling up our
sleeves and negotiating with state
governments city managers Mayors to help
kick-start our suppliers to restart
their operations
you know there are some really inspiring
stories where our supply chain teams
really fought hard to make sure that the
factories don't don't go down and and
it's also a testament to the resilience
of our supply partners
having said that
you know it was not all about resilience
and never give up attitude we had also
laid the foundation of having dual
sources
and also uh you know in many instances
we had uh many uh you know
things that that the that we had
simplified the parts that we had
simplified the supply chain design that
we had simplified due to which we were
able to get through the pandemic in much
better shape than rest of the automotive
uh it forced us to adapt you know we
encountered issues one at a time it was
really a team effort we heavily relied
on the government relations team you've
literally had to the covert pandemic as
you're aware you know happened at
different countries at different times
but unfortunately you need all the parts
to make the car so at any given point
there was one Factory that was lying
down there was one jurisdiction that was
being you know that didn't want to they
wanted to shut down a factory because
they had you had an outbreak so learning
the rules understanding coming up with
argument points leveraging the team and
getting those it was a it was a
difficult but good experience exactly we
learned a lot yeah and as we were just
figuring out to work with kovid then the
port congestion hit in on the west coast
uh Logistics lead time went up by you
know twice the twice the amount and and
we were operating with less than 35
percent accuracy in the system that
means at any given point the etas of the
vessels were 75 off
so
we figured out how to work with that and
then the chip shortage hits yeah the
chip shortage that was a nightmare uh
but we got through it I mean you know I
think uh it's a testament to the
tenacity of the team and the resilience
of our supplier Partners uh it's mostly
behind us and I think the results speak
for themselves uh Tesla was able to grow
production volumes at a time where the
rest of the industry had a hard time
staying flat I think they shrunk
actually
cumulatively and you know we're often
asked the question how do we manage
through it and and the answer is very
much kind of baked through the
presentations today first we design our
own Electronics so in order to control
cost we've really had to go and build
relationships with all the tier two
suppliers to negotiate them directly so
these relationships are formed you know
over 10 years ago and and we've really
gotten to know them well so when a
shortage hit we knew you know who to
escalate to who to call who to ask for
help and and really kind of swarming the
issue at the point of constraint
so the best team you know strong
relationships with vendors and then we
also have a pretty sophisticated
capacity planning function tier two
capacity needs to come on earlier than
tier one capacity tier three capacity
has to be even earlier and our team does
a very good job of having that strategic
alignment with all our partners to make
sure that the capacity is ready before
we need it we're a mission-based company
our goal is to put as many EVS out there
we did not let the pandemic phase us we
were full throttle and it was pedal to
the metal in terms of our demand signal
that also helped the the Silicon
industry has very long lead times they
invest billions of dollars in
sophisticated Fabs that take years to
build so that stability and demand is
something they appreciated and it's
something that is very uh very much a
Tesla thing
so this was looking back right this is
how we got here this is how we got from
zero to forty thousand cars a week let's
talk about how we get to 20 million
so the question gets asked you know is
Tesla going to basically break the chip
industry if they grow to 20 million
Vehicles the answer is no but let me
walk you through a logic on that so as
it stands right now a Tesla enabled with
a full self-driving computer it has four
times the Silicon content of a regular
vehicle ah so at about the two million
run rate we're consuming about 700
000 12 inch wafer equivalents that's the
industry term that's thrown around for
capacity in Silicon uh that's how much
we're using so a little bit below a
million and the global wafer capacity
based on the estimates we've seen is
about 135 million so we're about half a
percent off the industry not a lot
now if you get to 20 million when we get
to 20 million and if we don't make any
simplifications in terms of part count
which is also a separate work stream I
think Colin talked about it we talked
about it we're not going to have all
these different components we're really
going to simplify the architecture
because simpler is better but even if
you don't do that and we take the most
pessimistic case we're going to need 8
million Wafers okay and the industry is
going to scale at 20 to 200 million by
that point so still we're less than five
percent of the market share and if we
run the same offense we ran all along
and continue to work with our partners
and you know invest in Fabs and invest
in capacity uh we'll have the capacity
ready by the time we need it so I really
don't see this as an impediment from a
supply chain perspective to get to 20
million
now I would like to talk about a page
that we took out of the electronic
Playbook and applied it to the
mechanical side
our vehicles use currently the heat
pump-based technology for the thermal
system
but before heat pump our vehicles used
to have a dispersed thermal system
connected by hoses
engineering was inspired from circus or
circuit boards and then created a system
which was extremely integrated where 60
percent of the system was the size of a
basketball basketball where it contained
about 100 components 50 ceiling
interfaces and several several different
manufacturing processes all were
packaged into this tight tight size
now why are we talking about this
well we launched the system
right during the outbreak of the
pandemic in model y
the team was forced to manage 100 plus
components from different suppliers
around the world remotely
so
there are four videos playing at the
same time one is the video of the manual
line that was created when we started
the production and this manual line
produced a lot of quality issues let
alone throughput
so we quickly uh you know pivoted to a
semi-automated line but in spite of that
although the three throughput was uh
great uh the quality issues sustained
so our team decided that fully automated
is the only way to go
so before we automate the line
we created a 3D simulation now not many
companies or teams have this capability
where at this point now when a part gets
packed we have the ability to create a
3D simulation of all the complex
sub-assemblies that would be involved in
making the part and tell the supplies
exactly what equipment to purchase what
to test and and and and create an
end-to-end line in simulation and that's
what we did here so with the help of
assimilation we had a very detailed
sub-assembly cell which was juxtaped
post with the with the suppliers Factory
layout
and then we uh after a back and forth of
of iteration and optimizing the
processes we implemented this fully
automated line in less than eight months
and the results were remarkable
99 reduction in labor force
so in a line that would need 1000
Associates to build the super manifold
in full volume now just takes 10 10
Associates
and the quality also went up by an order
of magnitude
we have a defect rate of less than 0.005
percent and a super manifold rolls out
every seven seconds because we have
created many automated lines and these
factories are the size of two football
fields by the way
Russian after one-up me on that one 99
two football fields uh
so why are we talking about this
in a world where labor costs are
increasing
labor participation is decreasing
there's a huge turnover
and the cost of implementing automation
is going down by 3x in the next 10 years
this is how we are thinking about
complex assemblies and we are going to
push this type of thinking into our
supply base more and more who will be
building our complex assemblies
this is the only way we think we can
confidently scale to the 20 million
Vehicles Target
to summarize
we have laid the foundation in getting
ready to execute master plan 3.
our strategy is supply chain design
simplification
we are going to make sure that we have
more control into the tiers of the
supply chain
we are going to grow responsibly and
sustainably with our long-term partners
and we'll automate
yeah it's a you know going from zero to
forty thousand cars a week was was tough
I mean it took it took a lot of trial
and error it took a lot of learning
there was a lot of pain there's a lot of
mental Scar Tissue as Elon calls it
through that process but now now that
we're at that level and the foundation
is set going from 40 to 400 is not gonna
it doesn't really phase us we have a
capable team we've got capable external
partners that have you know gone through
hell with us a leadership team has
galvanized behind the mission
um and we're going to get it done
so I'd like to thank you for your time
and hand it off to Drew and Tom for the
next presentation thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone
um my name is Tom Joo I'm now
responsible for Global Production and
sales and deliverance service I joined
the company back in 2014 and I've been
running the company's business in
Greater China and APAC today I'm
representing all the gigafactories and
talk about how we can make more cars and
faster
so right now we have four vehicle
factories on three continents that serve
our markets the total number of
manufacturing employee is over 65 000.
this is also including our amazing team
in Reno they are making power change
battery packs and drive unit for our
vehicle factories the total installed
capacity in all these vehicle factories
about 2 million cars a year that's it
we're always looking for opportunity to
grow more capacity from the existing
footprint so you expect this number will
grow over time
to build more factories is the start to
building more cars and we certainly the
expert of it
um this is a before and after image
showing you the progress we made back in
2019 when we built a gig Factory in
Shanghai
um so in nine and a half months time we
built a Greenfield project to establish
the vehicle Factory in the three months
later we started delivering our first
customer vehicle
um people always ask me you know how
Tesla can build a factory that fast
really
um we learned from um our free
manufacturer a lot we talked to the
Survivor from the production Hill and
try to avoid all the mistakes we made
um and um we decided to design a
straight line with minimum number of up
and downs and turns for easier
manufacturability and easier
construction we also challenged all the
assumptions that people ever know to
build a vehicle Factory when we delete
and simplified all the redundancies and
the buffers that's helped us to save a
lot of time also we have a a very strong
in-house construction team in Tesla if
they're ever a job cannot be done by
others better and we bring this in-house
so we have this in-house construction
team have a full control over all the
activities on sites from design
engineering to construction site
management so this team not didn't just
built Shanghai they also built Giga
Berlin Giga taxes and Giga Nevada and
they're really the hero behind the
scenes
um like um Larsa shared earlier going
forward with the new platform the more
modular design and density densified
gigafactory will be able to make more
cars from even reduce the footprint that
also means we can build more Factories
at the same time with the drawing effort
of all manufacturing teams around the
globe
I'm happy to share early this morning
we'll hit the formula mark
for total Tesla rebuilt
in the uh the four Millions vehicle
actually built in this Factory when you
took a tour on our shop floor you
probably walked past it right so it took
us 12 years to build the first a million
vehicle
and about 18 months
um to the SEC built the second million
the third million took us 11 months and
just shortly less than seven months we
built the four million cars
so we're getting better at it faster
exponential growth
to the team
so what it takes to ramp a gigafactory
well if you have a 600 robots 10 000
training employees or 5 000 human and 5
000 optimists and hundreds of processes
you can do it sounds simple but it's
extremely hard so there's two key
metrics that we predominantly focused on
it's an overall equipment Effectiveness
in the cycle time in Tesla we're setting
the passing grade for our vehicle
factories with 90 oee and 45 second
cycle time what that means the oee
really evaluate the equipment uptime the
machine performance and the quality
simply put this is the actual production
time on a good quality product versus
the planned the productive time the
higher the better 45 second cycle time
that means you know you expect every 45
seconds there's a car running off the
final assembly line uh in the factory
um and the faster we rent
um the faster we can get to the economy
and scale
um if you look at the chart on the right
on the left
um Shanghai
um people to significantly drop our
labor hours per car
um during the ramp
um the little dip that has happened in
the last Q2 2022
um because of the the Kobe shutdown and
on the right it's a Fremont model y shop
even this is a 60 year old facility the
team there still be able to optimize the
material flow eliminate all the single
point of failure and drive higher
outputs hence reduce the labor hours and
actually this Factory keeps sending a
new record yesterday they just had a new
Factory Daily Record
Fremont team
absolutely
so
um how can we reduce the cycle in time
keep improved efficiency
we follow the philosophy
um Elon shared about the building rocket
which is questioning basically find the
right prompt to solve and we start with
delete simplify then we try to
accelerate pressurize the line and find
the if the the solution actually work
and at last we think about the
automation
um there's one example in gigafactory
Shanghai in the paint shop we find that
there's a
overlap baking range between the PVC
sealer and the top coat it was done by
two different ovens and we decided to
combine the two processes eventually
that helped us didn't just help us to
reduce the cycle time but also save the
nine percent of the energy consumption
and nine percent of CO2 emission also we
commonized the snx design in Fremont
right now we have a common body and
common headlamp we eliminate eliminated
about 40 parts and to reduce about 10 of
the cycle time so all these improvements
really help us to get to
um a faster ramp trajectory and we
didn't just learn from these high volume
existing factories we also learned from
the new factories most recently our
Berlin Factory team implemented a 5G
private Network on the shop floor helped
us to um overcome about the 90 percent
of the overcycle issues for a particular
process
um in GA shop we're going to soon
implement this globally so
um right now we have an integrated
Global organization from from production
all the way to a sales and delivery
service this will help us to strength
feedback loop between manufacturing and
the service we obviously want to bring a
delight for customer ownership
experience to our car owners and with
this direct feedback loop we be able to
turn customer escalations and the
feedback into Quick actions improvements
on shop floor immediately with that
effort in the past six months we'll be
able to reduce the time in service and
early ownership service also service
appointment with time significantly
so
um four factories not enough if we want
to hit the 20 million car a year Target
we're going to keep building new
factories the new lines
um and that will come up come up with a
new products as well
um and with all gigafactories and now in
one organization will be able to
replicate unified ideas across factories
also we will help the new factories that
rent faster and also produce a better
quality at a lower cost
now I'm going to hand over to Drew and
talk about a cell Manufacturing
thanks Tom yeah we're not just talking
about new vehicle factories but also new
cell factories and and we're going to
talk about how we follow the same model
when we do do so but first I thought I'd
just provide a little bit of an update
on cell production so remember battery
day we showed this video with the spoon
and how we went from dry powder to film
let's just say there's no spoon now
so many of you in this room saw this on
your tour today but you know here is our
dry electrode machine here in Texas one
of the lines we have installed here
fully automated no spoon from powder and
foil into coated electrode out
from from a peak productivity
perspective per tool perspective this is
over 20 times the productivity of the
tools that we showed folks on the tour
and Cato back in battery day so we've
made a lot of progress on the key one of
the key parts of the cell manufacturing
process
um and we've also continued to focus on
uh refining the way we make cells and
the factories that the cells go inside
we as you can see on this chart from
typical 2170 cylindrical cells to 4680
made a huge leap which is basically a 5x
reduction in the factory footprint and
volume and volume and footprint and then
from going from what we did in Fremont
and our pilot line to Texas we improved
further and we're approving again when
we go into Nevada and what this actually
represents is a series of actions taken
by a very integrated holistic uh design
team across you know the product design
the manufacturing design the process
design equipment design and the
facilities design they all need to work
together to make this happen and you can
see on the bottom just as an example of
simple Simplicity uh investment down and
scaling up you know Parts we've reduced
the number of parts in the cell the
number of processes a significant
reduction number of processes and and
collaborating with those five design
groups we've been able to uh result you
know build end up in a with a factory
that's 10 times smaller volumetrically
which means it's faster to get built
it's much lower capex per gigawatt hour
output and we can go and scale you know
to our objectives of you know 240 total
hours one Tower what our year of
stationary storage and 20 million
Vehicles a year
with the scalability that is required to
achieve our goals
um
and we're not just looking at the cell
Factor itself but also Upstream
materials where necessary what you see
here is a the rendering of the 50
gigawatt hour a year Corpus Christi
lithium Refinery that we've already
broken ground on
here in Texas uh the facility will start
commissioning by the end of 2023 uh this
year this is a good example of of
something where we're basically talking
about breaking ground and and and
starting commissioning within 10 months
uh and with with actual production
within 12 months that's the target
similar to what we did in Shanghai again
the result of collaboration and and you
know internal execution of construction
in partnership with local communities uh
30 this this site is 30 minutes from the
Corpus Christi ports located directly on
rail uh the process route we're taking
is a direct soda ash leech of the input
material which means there's no acid
roasting we don't have any of the sort
of waste products associated with uh an
acid roasting step were designed to
consume uh lithium spajamine which is a
very commonly traded lithium Rock but it
is flexible to other feeds from primary
and secondary sources
um and similarly we're working on our
our cathode facility here in Texas maybe
we've seen it as you're driving around
which is a 60 gigawatt hour a year
Catholic facility behind the main
building here 10-month build time there
as well uh the install the equipment's
being installed for the first line as we
speak and we'll be commissioning
starting next quarter so we we are doing
this where we need to uh our plan is not
to do it always there are lots of
confident companies out there but we are
also trying to sort of accelerate the
pace of the industry by trying some new
things that are a little bit more
scalable
and and de-risking certain innovations
that improve productivity per in terms
of capex per gigawatt hour and things
like that
um
and with that I think that sums up our
efforts on the factory side
um Mike you want to come up and we'll
talk about energy all right
[Applause]
all right
take it away all right here
hello everyone my name is Mike Snyder I
lead our mega pack organization I've
been with Tesla for almost nine years
I'm excited to talk to you today about
the mega pack product and the business
and some of the exciting things we have
ahead of us
from the beginning with this business we
have always focused on building
successful projects for our customers
and not just the batteries in the Box
we've built a hardware and a software
platform that is able to adapt to
environments all over the world
and that is able to scale for from small
island projects to large gigawatt hour
scale batteries
we've invested our time and our talent
to best understand every aspect
every step in the process and every risk
of a project
to ultimately provide a solution that is
that is thoughtful intuitive
provides Great Value to our customers
and is as plug and play as possible
and yeah just looking at these projects
it's incredible to see them all come
together in one in one Montage seeing
the future yeah yeah compressed it's 10
years of building these projects and and
it's it's incredible to see the impact
and to to see what we have in front of
us absolutely
we're on our sixth generation of our
industrial product which is the mega
pack XL that we're building out of the
out of Lathrop California
we've deployed over 16 gigawatt hours of
industrial and residential products
across 50 countries and really mega pack
is a market leader it's Best in Class in
efficiency reliability energy density
and easiest to install lowest cost to
install
and we call it Excel because it is
actually the like largest heaviest
object that you can
transfer around the roads of the world
without you know having to shut them
down and get crazy permits and things
like this so it is extra large and there
is not going to be an XXL let's just say
it that way
there's been incredible demand for the
project or for the product uh 2023 is
going to be a great year we have
gigawatt hour scale projects being built
um the Lathrop Factory continues to
scale and ramp up and there's new
products on the near-term roadmap so a
lot to look forward to
how did we get here
number one a maniacal focus on all
aspects of delivering stationary storage
what do we mean by that what are some
examples
as you see here the mega pack enclosure
for one example we designed the wire
ways directly into the base of the
enclosure so typically you need to
install a bunch of conduits and cables
under the ground now you can lift them
up and install them directly into the
base lower increasing the speed of
deployment and lowering the cost
next we see the batteries and the power
electronics and the Power Electronics is
really
the the Beauty and the Elegance of the
mega pack so this is what converts the
DC power to AC power on the grid
the brain is built directly into the
product
it is able to connect to any Grid in the
world right out of the box
it allows it to all the mega packs on a
given site to work as one unit
and really it's it's what makes it what
it is I think it's the most incredible
feature of of the mega pack as you build
out the full site what we end up with is
the most energy dense Solution on the
market upwards of 300 megawatt hours per
acre and just as a frame of reference
this solution is two times more power
dense than a typical gas speaker plant
so this is the future this this is where
we're going
this is the product that retires the
fossil fuels
yep one power plants at a time we talk
about Power Electronics a little bit
more
um Tesla is a leader in Power
Electronics we've deployed over 1.4
terawatts across energy storage and
vehicle
and we deliver more power Electronics
than the solar and the wind industry
combined on a per annum basis
and Power Electronics it's it's hard to
under to overstate how impactful they
are they are really the glue in the
sustainable energy economy between
generation storage and the end use you
know the the those Power Electronics
devices are switching you know thousands
of times per second hundreds of
thousands of times per second to
efficiently react to whatever is needed
uh either in the car or in the grid and
because they are so like sort of
software driven at their core they can
provide functionality that uh hasn't
been available to the Grid in the past
and it's one of the reasons why
Renewables and storage together are are
such a great solution
yeah
and one reason that we focus on Power
Electronics and control so much is
because of the impact that it has on the
projects directly
so just as an example here on the left
we have it we had a have a firmware
feature that we we call virtual machine
mode
and what virtual machine mode is is it
contributes to grid stability like a car
shock absorber that dampens oscillations
or vibrations and keeps the ride smooth
so you can imagine if if you can't if
you don't dampen those those vibrations
the vehicle could lose control or or
someone could get hurt on the grid you
could have a blackout
we have one grid operator that's
utilizing virtual machine mode and said
they will not operate their Grid at 100
Renewables unless they have this feature
unless they have virtual machine mode
working yeah and they tried and it
didn't work very well and virtually why
is it virtual machine it's like
synthetic inertia where you turn the
battery power plant into like through
software behaving like it's a giant
spinning machine literally and and and
that like inertia stabilizes the grid
um and you don't but you don't need a
giant spinning machine you don't need
like a huge phosphate power plant or a
giant Hydro turbo you can just have the
battery do it
um and you can program it to whatever
you need at that part of the Grid or
even have it be dynamically changing as
the as the grid conditions change right
and that's why we focus so much on and
we believe it's the future of how
batteries are going to add value it's
going to be more about adding power
stability just as it is about energy yep
yep
Auto bidder is another software feature
I wanted to mention Auto bidder is an
autonomous energy trading platform that
in its most basic senses buying energy
low and selling it high and the the
owner can net the difference of that but
operating battery storage is actually
very complex
um upwards needing upwards of hundreds
or even thousands of decisions every
five minutes it's much more complex than
a PV a solar plant or a wind plant or a
thermal thermal battery or thermal
Generation Plant
and it's mostly because of the
versatility and the ability of the
battery to provide so much value in
different ways that these decisions need
to be made in real time in order to
optimize and and get the most value out
of the batteries they can
so there wasn't a solution that existed
in the market so we built one ourselves
in the market that we've been to markets
we've deployed them in in Australia and
Texas and the UK it has proven to be a
market leader we're continuing to invest
in Auto bidder as we expand to New
Markets
second point of how we got here a
Relentless focus on speed of execution
and and there's two points to be made
here first one isn't building factories
what you're seeing here is a time lapse
of the mega Factory that was built in
Lathrop we took it from a JCPenney
Distribution Center to a world-class
manufacturing facility in less than 12
months which is which is incredible and
really the way that we did this is
similar to what my colleagues have
described it's it's leveraging the
vertical integration of Tesla it's it's
getting the vehicle manufacturing team
in the same room as construction and
engineering and making decisions quickly
with all the decision with all the
stakeholders and decision makers
we're using the lessons learned from
Lathrop as we speak as we plan for our
next factories
second it's about installing projects
faster
I've mentioned this already but Plug and
Play is kind of at the core of what
we're going for
over the past four years we've we've
increased the installation speed by 4X
and we've reduced the total labor
involved across both construction and
Manufacturing by 3x
we think that this is key to unlocking
our ability to scale and our customers
ability to scale with us we need to be
laser focused on reducing that time from
when the mega pack leaves the factory to
when it is operational on the grid
and it's not just about uh centralized
storage it's also about distributed
storage the future roadmap of of uh well
at least here at Tesla
um and and maybe some of you know about
this sort of retail plan we have here in
in Texas and I just wanted to talk a
little bit about how that all fits
together so Tesla electric really
unlocks the full value of distributed
energy and storage products so it
enables our customers to become their
own utility the data on the page is from
our South Australia virtual power plant
another Tesla electric setup that we
have
over the over 2022 it's 5 000 customers
that we we have the data for you can get
a sense for what's happening so just if
they were being provided default utility
service and you looked at the cost of
serving them that electricity on average
140 a month if they all had solar and
powerwall but the solar and power wall
wasn't interacting with the grid wasn't
participating in the energy Market the
cost of serving that customer would go
from would have go from 140 a month to
70 a month
if you if Tesla electric is operating
um those assets in an intelligent way to
benefit the grid
uh Tesla electric being basically a
software that we developed out of Auto
bidder for the purposes of of these
distributed energy resources we can
actually
pay the customers to bring their their
their Energy Services to the grid that's
what happened in Australia last year and
Australia is a little bit of a special
case there they represent the future
South Australia in particular solar and
wind supplied 70 percent of South
Australia's energy in 2022. that
compares to 30 percent in Texas and 35
in California but it but this is a this
is an indication of where this is all
headed of both centralized and
distributed um storage resources uh
providing the the key to unlocking fully
renewable grids and Tesla electric is
the retail plan that we're using to
bring that to bear for our our customers
that have our products
um
and you know this is how we're rolling
it out
uh first as it exists uh it's available
for uh in Texas for people who have
power walls in their homes
but we need to extend beyond that over a
billion people live in markets with
competitive retail electricity
and there's over two trillion in annual
energy spend in these markets this is a
huge opportunity
and the Our intention is to bring this
to you know Market by market in the same
way that we've approached Tesla
Insurance where we can bring value to
our customers to reduce their total cost
of ownership of our products
so actually what we're going to do next
and this is pretty exciting here in
Texas Yeah by by this summer we're going
to offer a retail electricity plan to
people who have our cars where they can
have unlimited overnight home charging
for thirty dollars a month
this is part of reducing the total cost
of ownership of our vehicles and the
reason why we can do this is because
Texas has a ton of wind and in Texas the
wind blows at night so actually serving
these customers with electricity at
night for their cars is the best thing
to do for everyone and so this is a way
to incentivize people to charge at home
at night directly from Renewable Power
it's part of the grand master plan we
talked about at the beginning so we're
very excited about this and we do see
this similar to Tesla insurance as I
said as further reducing the total cost
of ownership of electric vehicles
so putting this all together
we're really at the beginning of this uh
massive ramp in energy storage
deployment
and yeah yeah reflecting back on the on
the master plan we talk about tens of
terawatt hours needing tens of terawatt
hours of stationary storage so we have
our sites set on annual production rates
of one terawatt hour which is 25x our
capacity at Lathrop
in the in in the near term we see we see
really strong demand for the mega pack
product over 100 gigawatt hours per year
uh in 2023 and growing by over 100
gigawatt hours per year over the next
few years so the demand is there and
naturally as we continue to focus on
cost and speed and value the things that
we've mentioned it's clear we need to
build more capacity and we need to ramp
it quickly
so while the challenge is Big it's also
a huge opportunity for Tesla it's huge
opportunity for for the mega pack
business and I'm excited to see the
impact that it's going to make on our
grid transition as am I yeah all right
all right thank you thank you all yes
all right and uh
Lori
Brandon come on up
hi I'm Brandon with the legal team thank
you not just for uh coming but being
investors
now we have we have an active and
engaged board and management team we've
met with you and today is the
culmination of that we've heard you
which is why we're excited to share this
investor day with you now you will hear
more from our board at the appropriate
time but for now I'm excited to
introduce Lori Shelby who's going to
discuss sustainability and our employees
Lori
thank you Brandon
hi everyone my name is Lori Shelby and I
lead the environmental health safety
security and sustainability team I've
been with Tesla for five and a half
years
so I'm going to talk about Tesla's
impact
and of course that starts with our
awesome team members so you've heard a
lot today about our amazing products our
process our software you've seen lots of
numbers and lots of graphs you've also
heard a common theme and that common
theme is that Tesla's team is what
drives our success and makes a
difference
whether you're in our factories in our
sales service and delivery centers our
warehouses are in the field you can see
and you can feel the collaboration
that's happening and you also can see
the pride that everyone has in working
for Tesla so before I go on I want to
give a big shout out and a thank you for
our Tesla team globally so let's
[Applause]
that was great that was great thank you
so we are creating a lot of meaningful
work through our jobs
we're a huge employer and we're growing
every day we're at 129k
and more than half of our team Works in
vehicle Manufacturing
and almost 60 percent of our team is
based in the U.S
people want to join our mission
and we need to grow and we need to hire
the best people Engineers want to work
for Tesla look at number one and number
two SpaceX and Tesla
in 2021 we got 3 million applicants 3
million that's incredible
and our culture our culture at Tesla is
anyone at any time can raise an idea or
make an improvement suggestion across
safety people cost production quality
because we have a very simple process
called take charge and take charge is
really Employee Engagement and as take
charges go up as you can see in this
graph injuries go down
and you know why
people who do the work the people who do
the work know how to improve the work
sustainability sustainability is
everything it's our mission you've heard
about it all day part of our master plan
but at Tesla we don't just tick boxes to
meet a requirement we really focus on
the impact that our products and our
software will deliver
in 2021
our customers avoided
8.4 million metric tons of greenhouse
gas
that's equivalent to taking
1.7 million ice Vehicles off the road
for a full year yes
yes
we're also focusing on doing really good
work and driving sustainability into our
operations we have year-over-year
reduction in our water use in our waste
and we're growing and building a
renewable energy program within our
operations just like supercharging as
you heard
so
it's not just about our products it's
the way we make our products both phases
Tesla our company is solving both sides
of the clean energy equation
we've got the clean generation the clean
storage we also have zero emission
transport as this slide shows from 2012
to 2021 our products generated more
energy that was consumed by all Tesla
vehicles and our factories
it's amazing
yeah I like the collapse yeah I'll take
I'll take I'll I'll take laughs
so
our vehicles use less emissions than gas
powered vehicles
even in the worst case scenario a
hundred percent cold grid
the model 3 has less emissions than the
average ice car
and we're only gonna get better you
heard about that today every product we
make is more efficient every Factory we
build is more sustainable so it's only
going to get better and better
so as we build our zero emission future
we've been talking with our stakeholders
with our shareholders
about how do we improve our reporting
framework and we are aligning with the
tcdf
so
tcfd so we're aligning with the tcfd
which I know many of you have been
asking us about
I also want you to stay tuned because
there's going to be much more
coming in our impact report so thank you
all and up next is Zach kirkhorn
[Applause]
thank you Lori
all right so this is our last section of
our prepared remarks today
we'll kind of take what we've discussed
today and summarize it at the corporate
level for our financials
maybe before I jump into the details
here we've never done an investor day as
a company we've never brought our
leadership team out and asked them to
talk about the things that they're
working on
so you know I feel very fortunate to be
able to work alongside this group of
people and support their teams and I
also just want to thank them they're in
a room in the back listening to this for
all of the work that they put into today
and getting the company to where it is
today so thank you to the Tesla team
[Applause]
when we were preparing for today folks
were asking well Zach what should we
talk about and really the only guidance
we gave folks is well talk about the
things that you're working on and talk
about it in the context of the master
plan
and what did almost everybody talk about
today in great detail all of the work
that they're doing to take cost out
because in this industry in this
business
you survive or you die based upon the
ability to manage your costs
and so I'd like to talk about cost as
well
if we look at our longest running scale
production product this is the model 3.
we reached 5 000 cars per week which was
our design capacity in mid 2018
and since then we've taken 30 percent of
cost out of this product
and there's two points I want to make
about this the first is that cost
reduction as you have heard throughout
the course of the day is deeply
ingrained in our culture and I think one
of the most important reasons why we are
here today as a company
the second point that I want to make is
that
when we're working on cost reduction
it's easy just to take cost out and make
our products worse
but we have to take cost out and improve
our products at the same time this is
the hard thing to do but it's the
necessary thing to do to continue to
move forward
and if you look at a version of a model
3 that we've built today and you compare
it back to a model 3 that we built in
2018 there's a long list of improvements
that we put into the car while also
taking cost out of the product
cost reduction doesn't just come from
one place there's no Silver Bullet here
and we push the boundaries on volume
with the model 3 Program increasing
volume 3x over this period of time we've
improved productivity so in our Fremont
Factory we are twice as productive now
as we were in mid 2018. we've made a lot
of progress on overhead efficiencies and
product improvements as we've discussed
and a long list of other things
including localization our Factory in
Shanghai
and as we ramp up volume and as we find
efficiencies we work with our suppliers
to do the same and that leads to
material cost reductions that improve
the affordability of our products
and as we look forward to our next-gen
vehicle
our Target is to reduce 50 of cost and
we've talked about that a bit earlier
today
from going from the model snx platform
to the 3ny platform we took out fifty
percent of costs so the task here is to
do it again
and this is very important because as we
improve affordability
the number of customers who have access
to our products dramatically increases
and as we link this back to our master
plan it enables an exponential growth in
our volume with linear reductions in the
cost of our products
the second point I'll make here is that
and again cost reductions don't come
from any single one place and so you can
see the buckets here on the vehicle side
battery and powertrain manufacturing
cost reductions and others these buckets
are relatively equal in size and so in
order to take fifty percent of cost out
of the product we have to go through
everything
but more importantly than just the cost
of the car up front
when we're transitioning to a
sustainable economy particularly with
vehicle ownership it's really important
to think about the lifetime cost of of
the products
and
this chart here is showing what the
total cost of ownership per mile is over
the course of five years and we have to
think about financing costs Insurance
costs the cost of power Drew talked a
little bit about that with the plans
that we're doing in Texas wear and tear
and maintenance on the cars Etc and
we're already at a place today in the
U.S where a base model 3 on a cost per
mile basis is less than a Toyota Corolla
which is the highest selling car in the
world and as we move towards our next
gen platform we will continue to reduce
this and as we work on Robo taxi
variants of this platform this cost will
come down even further
so this is a product that has that we
expect to have substantially lower cost
per mile than the highest volume
products in the world
the next thing on cost reduction I want
to talk about is operating expenses you
spend a lot of time on our earnings
calls talking about gross margins and
product costs we don't spend a lot of
time talking about Opex but I think this
is one of the really important parts of
our story
so since 2018 we've reduced our non-gaap
Opex 60 as a percent of Revenue and 75
percent on a per delivered car basis uh
this is quite staggering and I want to
go into the details about how we've done
this
the first component of Opex which is r d
the the single most important thing here
is that we constrain the number of
programs that we work on so minimizing
the number of programs that we're
running in parallel and the key here is
to maximize the revenue and cash
generated from every program that we
work on and also maximize the technology
sharing between the programs so we
talked a little bit about how Power
Electronics in our energy business is
shared with Power Electronics in our
vehicle business
if we look at the SG a side of this I
think the story here is pretty traumatic
so we're showing here a comparison of SG
a per card delivered compared to the
traditional Auto industry which is both
an oem and the dealership Network and
our estimates are that we're 60 to 70
percent lower on a per car basis and if
you turn this into Dollars this is many
thousands of dollars per car
this is part of the reason why on the
last earnings call I made the comment
that we think about operating margin
more so than gross margin as a company
because the uh the integration that we
have here on the SG a side particularly
with vertical integration into our
dealership Network
this provides efficiencies that give us
a competitive Advantage from cost
structure standpoint relative to other
companies
the other thing that I'll note here is
that this wasn't always the case
and it wasn't that long ago where these
bars would be inverted
and if we go back a little bit in time
and we talk about when we launched model
3 in the Fremont Factory
we went from 2 000 cars per week which
was snx adding 5 000 a week to that for
model 3 got us to 7 000 cars a week
you've heard some folks here today talk
about production hell but I don't think
we've ever talked about as a company as
back office operations hell which also
happened at the same time and seven
thousand cars a week 350 000 cars a year
we want to go to 20 million cars a year
and we're struggling at seven thousand
and we're saying to ourselves
we have to completely rethink the way
that we're managing our back office
operations if we have any hope of
efficiently scaling this company
and so this began a process that we're
still continuing to work on today but
it's something that we refer to as the
Tesla operating system so in the same
way that we're vertically integrated
into the software that manages our cars
we've also vertically integrated into
the software that runs our company
and all of our major departments in the
company are using not all of them yet
but almost all of them are using our
in-house software most recently we
removed third-party recruiting software
and we're now running our own recruiting
software as a company
and this matters a lot because rather
than having a complex web of third-party
systems that are generic solutions that
take a lot of effort to customize for
our particular needs we've been able to
put in place within in-house
applications engineering team dedicated
lightweight software that does only what
we needed to do and nothing more
and that team works very closely with
process Improvement teams that sit
within the business
who are looking through all of the
processes that we're managing as a
company and following the exact same
process that Tom mentioned in the
manufacturing space to look at our
processes delete process steps that we
don't need simplify process steps that
are existing and automate what's
remaining
and the results of this have been quite
staggering to be frank I think it's
exceeded our expectations as well
on the left side of this chart are some
examples of the efficiency improvements
that we've seen within our SG a areas as
a result of the strategy the North
American Sales team is four times more
efficient now than they were in 2018
order operations team Financial Services
I mean these levels of improvement are
large and I don't there's not enough
pixels on the slide here to list out
everything so it's just a couple of
examples
and then in the same way that when we
look to take cost out of our products we
want to feature up the product or
improve the product while taking cost
out the same has been true with the use
of Tesla operating system and that
integration with our process Improvement
teams within the company and so we've
increased performance and added
capabilities while also dramatically
reducing cost on a per car basis
there's a list of self-service
functionality that we've put in place
which customers like it also simplifies
our operations behind the scenes we've
used the Tesla operating system to
expand into our captive Insurance space
which we are fully vertically integrated
into we run our own in-house software we
have our own agents our own claim
software and and claims folks who run
our insurance business this is also very
important because as a technology
company data is very important and we
use these systems and the access to the
data in those systems to pull out
extremely granular and targeted
reporting that enables us to see every
aspect of our business in real time so
we can make adjustments to our
operations as needed and there are
sometimes examples where we say man I
wish we were tracking this piece of data
well you know it's a team's meeting away
from the applications engineering team
to make a request and then we can start
tracking that data and make those
changes and so the feedback loop
associated with process Improvement
inside the company is is pretty
astounding
the last thing I'll just mention here
which is something I'm personally quite
proud of we've made a lot of progress in
our closed processes within the finance
team getting our 10q and 10K filed it's
amongst the fastest of the 20 largest
market cap companies so great work to
the finance team here
so all of this work on cost reduction is
extremely important because we have a
lot of money to spend ahead of us to
achieve our goals within the master plan
so we've mentioned over the course of
the day today 20 million annual vehicle
production as our Target one terawatt
hour of annual energy storage production
and then expanding cell production
service and charging in line with the
growth of those other businesses
and so we've estimated what we think the
total cost to get there will be and
there's certainly error bars around
these numbers as as we continue to
progress and innovate but of this we've
spent about 28 billion dollars of that
so far in the history of the company
and
maybe this total investment looks large
I actually think it's quite small
relative to our Ambitions and if you
look at our 2022 operating cash flows
and you you just say well let's assume
some modest growth to that maybe not all
that much
if you're being conservative but the
ability to pay for this level of
investment from the forecast that we
have is is very achievable for us
I'm often asked about Capital allocation
I think our strategy here is very
straightforward I touched upon it a
little bit in our last slide but just to
be explicit about it
obviously the priority here is to ensure
that we're using Capital to run the
day-to-day operations of the business
this is a working capital intensive
business and this has to be managed very
carefully and so you know over the
course of a quarter there can be
multi-billion dollar swings in our cash
balance up and down just depending upon
the timing of when we build and deliver
cars so we obviously have to have money
set aside for that downside protection
is another really important area where
we have money set aside for that
and over the last couple of years
throughout the pandemic I think this
just highlights why being ready for
downside protection is important
preserving daily operations is the
engine that then generates cash that
allows us to reinvest into the growth of
the business
and I'm very proud that over the last
couple of years despite the ups and
downs in the macro environment and
interruptions to supply chains we have
never once pulled back on our
investments in growth so that remains a
huge priority for us
we do then after investing in growth we
look at opportunistic ways to spend our
cash these are more financially oriented
where if a return exceeds a hurdle then
we can place cash in that this is part
of our story of cost reduction in the
Fremont Factory
and then on the excess side you know
this is where you know the board meets
on a regular basis and thinking about
what our cash flow projections are
looking forward and whether it makes
sense to do BuyBacks or dividends
so to wrap up the finance portion of the
presentation today
a couple of key messages I just want to
leave you all with here
is that we use innovation at an intense
level
to drive costs down and improve the
efficiency of the business
and the reason this is so important is
it allows us to improve product
affordability this is particularly the
case when we move to our next Generation
platform
improving affordability allows us to
comfortably make investments that grow
volume that volume generates cash that
then allows us to make more Investments
and as we integrate that going forward
it's our belief as a leadership team
here at Tesla that we're going to
achieve unprecedented scale in the
manufacturing space
and this is what's ultimately required
to accelerate the world's transition to
sustainable energy
so with that this completes the prepared
portion of today
we're going to take a short break and
then we'll resume with the live q a
thank you all very much
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
project boys
do the mic
oh I can talk
all right so
um
well let's see so this is uh we're uh
probably the most significant
announcement of the day is that we're
excited to announce that we're going to
be building a gigafactory in Mexico
so um
yeah and we'll have a
you know obviously a grand opening and
you know uh groundbreaking and whatnot
but we're excited to announce that that
uh the next uh Tesla gigafactory will be
in Mexico uh near Monterey
so super excited about it
um now I do want to emphasize we will
continue to expand production at all of
our existing factories so including
California Nevada
here in Texas obviously and uh Berlin
Shanghai so we intend to increase
production at all factories uh so the
gego Mexico would be supplemental to the
output of all the other factories so
this is not to be clear moving moving
output from anywhere to anywhere it is
simply about expanding uh total Global
output uh yeah so it's gonna be good
um
so
peanut gallery
um anyway so this I think that's uh
yeah we're quite excited to announce
that um in fact I believe the governor
is here
it's hard to see welcome
Secretary of State I believe so anyway
uh it's uh we look forward to it and
having a big event to for the great
groundbreaking and and opening so let's
see with that we can move to I guess q a
uh We've obviously got a significant
bench strength here
um probably like a bench
and uh anyway
we maybe have too many people on stage
but we'll try to answer questions within
reason
um you know this is meant to be kind of
more of a long-term
sort of discussion as opposed to
uh you know what will be the production
for the rest of the quarter type of
thing
um so let's try to orient out questions
towards long-term value creation and
with that far away
Rob
it's uh Rod lash with the wolf research
um
very exciting plans about the the Next
Generation vehicle and powertrains and
and batteries I was hoping you can maybe
talk to us a little bit about the
timeline for deploying this and it
sounds like it's more than just a
vehicle this is a kind of a paradigm
change on how vehicles are assembled how
batteries are put together and
everything and does that also just get
reconfigured into everything that you do
so the model wise that are being built
here will be built very differently in
the future maybe just give us some feel
for what happens from here and what's
the timeline for implementation
well talk a little bit about that but
um
broadly speaking the most profound
architectural changes will be in future
Vehicles
retooling a factory means bringing the
factory down for an extended period of
time and uh
that's that would prefer not to do that
I think
um
but do we but there are variants in how
model Y is produced so we've got
variance where there's a rear casting
where there's a front and rear casting
and we have the uh
structural battery pack
and then there are a number of smaller
improvements that occur but I think for
for really really big changes those
would be future vehicles
um yeah I know you guys want to add
larsberry
I mean yeah so I mean as far as I agree
with you 100 Elon it's it's it's really
easy to put Innovations in new vehicles
but long term we'll obviously bring them
back we've always talked about that but
we don't want to take our factories down
as far as what timeline goes um you know
we're going to go as fast as we can left
to right as always you know Elon alluded
to the fact that Mexico will build our
next end vehicle but we will also be
doing that in our other plants and so
it's really about getting them all up
and running we expect that to be a huge
volume product and
now we're going to move that quickly
over the next couple years
let's go through all them
uh thanks uh first and Nora Buena Mexico
vamos that's great congratulations uh
Elon
um a question on
applying first principles thinking and
Innovation to an area that up to now has
seemingly been outside of of your
control and that is on mining and
extraction of some of the key materials
I believe a couple years ago you you had
a patent on sodium chloride to extract
lithium from some from some Clays and
Spa gyming clay and things of that
nature any how how does that fit into
the plan of maybe bringing real
Innovation into a mining sector that
could use a little you know maybe waking
up and getting those costs down because
that could be a real gating Factor it
seems
well we're we're going to address
whatever we think the limiting factor is
at any point in time
so we would like to do the least amount
possible
so we don't want to get into the mining
or finding sector we will do that if we
have to um
I I do think the the focus really should
be on refining capacity
um
you know do we need to make just a very
uh Giant
amount of anode cathode lithium
lithium hydroxide lithium lithium
carbonate it there's it's really the
refining capacity that is uh the biggest
choke point
um
yeah so that's why we're building a
lithium refinery in Corpus Christi
in terms of uh
the mining companies that are out there
uh and looking at that part of the value
chain so we do have large suppliers of
lithium right now and we they are aware
of you know how we're approaching the
Corpus Refinery and the Technologies
we're trying there and the reason we're
making them aware of it is because we
think they're fundamentally more
scalable and as we prove them out we
plan to
to share that with them because as Elon
says like it's not really like we want
to do these things we're doing them
because it's not happening fast enough
so if if we can prove that it can be
done faster the intention is to transfer
that knowledge to our our large our
current suppliers and the same is
actually true it was actually a clay
process that that we were playing with
and we continue to work on same is true
on that so we've worked with our
suppliers as well on trials and and
we're sharing knowledge there and the
intention is just to help the whole
world do this better uh and and
ultimately this here is getting the
lithium out or whatever it is out of the
ore
and we're obviously building a cathode
processing facility just adjacent to
this this building so a little further
down the road you'll see another large
construction that's for uh cathode
refining
um
but like I said would really prefer if
others did that uh we're doing it
because we have to do it because we want
to yeah and in that case there just
isn't really any large-scale cathode
production in the United States and it
needed to be done
um and and again if we're going to do it
we're going to try to do it from a first
principle's perspective so we're we have
tried a bunch of new things there we're
confident that they will work and as
they prove out again we want to bring
them back to our supplier so they can
build new facilities more quickly with
less investment
all right let's go to Ben hi uh Ben
Kayla for Bear uh so similar
um on the renewable side is there more
that you can do uh in in Tesla uh to to
nudge the rest of the renewable industry
to speed up since it's such a big pillar
of uh the Master Plan Three
well uh I mean I don't know what more we
can do but
I
I can say that if there's like
entrepreneurs out there that want to
have like a guaranteed chance of success
it would be refining lithium or anode
and cathodes or any any materials
whatsoever for
uh lithium ion cells as no-brainer
um
yep
I think
we're doing everything we can so
yeah on the on the renewable energy
thing uh the thing that that we can do
Tesla
um is the more we reduce the cost of
storage the more we reduce the cost of
stationary storage and the more we bring
like flexible load to the Grid in the
form of like cars charging at the right
times the more valuable Renewables are
um because in like Texas right now I
wasn't joking like there's a lot of wind
um and at night wind is there's like
almost too much wind because they don't
want to turn the nukes off or whatever
so
um so so so so bringing really Low Cost
Storage onto the grid makes Renewables
more valuable which ultimately will
accelerate their deployment so that
that's how we focus on it I guess
yeah Felipe
thank you it's um Jeffries I've got two
questions the first one when I think
about
in this industry everybody wants to be
Tesla every comic or is trying to
emulate what you're doing well done the
one thing they don't do is
um
focus on having as much growth as
possible with as few models as possible
so I'm just trying to understand as you
aim for 20 million units in 2030. how
many models do you think
you need to get there and how does it
fit into your drive to hyperscale
um how do you manage this and also the
fact that probably consumers at some
point don't want to see a test route the
same Tesla at every street corner so I'm
just trying to get your your sense of
that
and my other question is on um
on bi-directional I mean you you talked
a lot about making you know a world more
Renewables and better usage of cars I
think bi-directional charging is one way
of better using cars but you seem to
have been reluctant about
doing that in the past so I'm just
wondering what your latest views are on
the topic
sure on bi-directional
um
it uh
it wasn't like a conscious decision to
not do it it just wasn't a priority at
the time I think it's maybe the way to
think about it as we looked as we
continue to improve the Power
Electronics in our vehicle
we've found ways to bring broader
actionality while actually reducing cost
of Power Electronics in the vehicle and
as at all things Tesla the the goal is
usually to get more for less and so we
are in the middle of kind of like a
Power Electronics retool I would say
that will bring that functionality to
arvo all of our vehicles over the next
you know two years let's say
um but but it's
yeah I guess that's how I'll say there
yeah I don't think very many people are
going to use bi-directional charging
unless you have a power wall because if
you unplug your car your house goes dark
and this is extremely inconvenient
yeah most of the value it comes in
charging the car at the right time it's
not really about sending energy the
other way
um yeah I mean if you have a power wall
that can take the house load then you
can use the your car as Supple as a
supplementary energy source to the power
wall and then you know you're not going
to drive everyone Crazy by unplugging
your car
um and having the house go off
so I think there's some value there as a
supplemental energy source down the road
where if you have a power wall you've
not
diminished the
convenience of of the people in the
house
and the question of number of models
sorry what oh how many models Vehicles
not that many
um really 10 I don't know not that many
um there's I mean what's happened with
conventional cars is people have run out
of things to do so you run out of things
to do they just end up reshuffling the
deck and you have pretty much the same
I mean how many variants of a car are
there on the road because like hundreds
but they're are they good variants no
mostly not
they're just variants with the sake of
variants
um and but look at what how is have
things converged with the phone
I mean there used to be hundreds of flip
phones now what do we have
it'll be like that
George
George genericus from kanakor genoti I
just had a question about your plans to
grow
market share in China and also whether
or not the political tensions between
United States and China impact your
long-term Ambitions there thank you
I don't know hey Tom uh don't don't uh
sweat too hard
[Laughter]
well we're still growing our market
share in China
um quite strongly actually
um especially um you know early this
year we had this price adjustment after
that we actually generated a huge demand
more than we can produce really
um and um as Elon said as long as you're
offer a product with value at affordable
price you know you don't have to worry
about demand that's basically the
philosophy that we follow we'll try
everything to cut cost from supply chain
from improved efficiency in the factory
and pass down that value to our
customers I think you guys as long as
we're continuing to do that I'm not too
concerned about the market share in
China
in the second part geopolitical no one
else we do our best we we actually
create a lot of jobs to look low
community and we generally also
at our suppliers
factories will create a lot of jobs as
well and we'll contribute a lot into the
local economy I think you know as long
as we're needed in this country I don't
see there much of the risk of that
Colin Colin Rush from Oppenheimer you
know one of the things I was struck by
in the presentation was the the
operational efficiency metrics that you
guys are talking about can you talk a
little bit about the velocity of
learning cycles and how you guys track
that and and think about that as an
organization as you work into a variety
of other areas from from an innovation
perspective
anyone want to try that I mean I'll say
one very high level thing which is you
can't improve something you don't
measure and we're like ruthless
measurers at Tesla and once you start
measuring things that contribute to
operational efficiency you actually have
a path to doing something about it
so I guess the key is a good measuring
stick
okay
it's something I should say with respect
to uh demand which I I've said a few
times over the years but it's sometimes
uh
it needs to be said again which is
um the
overwhelmingly the uh there's the the
desire for people to own a Tesla is
extremely high the limiting factor is
their ability to pay for a Tesla not do
they want a Tesla
um it's it's easy for people in this
room to lose sight of that if if your
income is far in excess of what a car
costs then you look at value for money
but you do not consider affordability
but for the vast majority of people it
is affordability driven
this is why we cannot simply double the
price of the car
or you could say and to think about
things in the limit where if you hadn't
you know a infinitely desirable car but
uh it costs 10 million dollars uh it
wouldn't matter because people are not
cannot most people do not have that so
demand is
very much a function of affordability
not desire
very important one of the things we
weren't sure about was the price
elasticity of demand for for Teslas so
like as we lower the price
how much this demand increase
um
and we found that even small changes in
the price have a big effect on demand
very big
so that was a good thing to learn
um
yeah
and then as this autonomy question
is very very big
um because you could potentially have I
don't know five times the utility
of the asset that you currently have so
if passenger car is
10 or 12 hours a week of usage
um plus a lot of parking expenses
uh an autonomous car could be 50
to 60 hours a week or something like
that
um
and you could get rid of a lot of
parking expenses so
you know if this if this is true then as
autonomy is effectively turned on for
the fleet
it may be the probably will be the
biggest asset value increase in history
overnight
Emmanuel
thank you thank you so much Emmanuel
Rosner from Deutsche Bank
um so as you start launching this next
Generation vehicle and ramping up volume
what will be your nearest term priority
in terms of
segment or Vehicles Focus the the slide
that you showed with two vehicles on the
wrap seemed based on the form factor one
of them maybe looks like a van another
one looks like maybe like a smaller
vehicle like potentially a model too I
guess what is the nearest Focus for you
in terms of ramping up the next gen
vehicle and how do you make sure that by
lowering the price point uh so much
because the cost is going down 50 you're
not cannibalizing demand you know for
your existing vehicles
I mean demand for our vehicles in terms
of desire to own them may as well be
infinite
uh it's indistinguishable from infinite
at this point uh the affordability is
what matters so as you make the car more
affordable we will have demand to go
crazy basically
the issue is how do we build the cars
the hard part is building the cars
I can't emphasize that enough the hard
part is building the cars and the entire
supply chain that goes with the cars
this is a
Logistics challenge
of extraordinary difficulty
um
all the things that have to go into the
car have to scale with the car while
everything is doing in an exponential
ramp
and if you miss even one of those things
doesn't matter why earthquake flood fire
Revolution I thought I've heard them all
I mean
any part of that supply chain gets
interrupted
you're now feeling you have a seizure
the hard part is building the cars
by far
and the supply chain that goes with it
I'm like do you guys want to talk about
supply chain stuff
yeah they might I think you know and the
presentation I'd mentioned um Perfection
is a passing great we really need
everything to happen perfectly and the
strategy for mitigating the different
risks some of which were anticipated and
some weren't is really bespoke to the
situation and and then really the
you need subject matter expertise and a
deep knowledge of the particular supply
chain you're managing to come up with
those strategies so we've we've seen
everything from as Elon mentioned you
know first the the tariffs that flew
back and forth then the ocean Logistics
issue a chip shortage covid floods there
was a fire and a Fab in Japan that
knocked down
there was a massive uh covered spike in
Malaysia where a lot of the chips are
the back end of a lot of chips is what
was down there and Noir this was one
that Elon was involved with as well and
um yeah that's
it's nerve-wracking but somehow it works
yeah and
um although it's difficult I think we
have been laying the foundation to be as
intimate to our all the tiers of the
supply chain building that control and
you know directing the different tiers
of supply chain that's the way we are
trying to mitigate the risks that come
with it
you know again dual sourcing triple
sourcing having redundancy uh is the way
we've been trying to mitigate for it
yeah on on that point when we think
about Vehicles when you think about 3y
as an architecture SX as an architecture
our next Generation platform is more
than one segment and really we're
thinking about all the segments that are
available that we haven't captured and
where the market would be and designing
it with our supply chain Partners so
that we can go quickly through those
segments for where we need but to elon's
point if you make a car desirable
and affordable
um you know oftentimes it doesn't
necessarily matter what segment it's in
because it's one that you want and we've
seen that with model 3 when a lot of
people thought the sedan was not going
to be a great hit but we sell tons of
them so
um the Next Generation platform is not
one vehicle it is it is multiple and
it's on the segment
um that we will you know really try and
focus on the affordability and
desirability point moreover than where
we started
yeah I mean there's like I think
it's an old saying like battles the one
with tactics or is the one with
Logistics uh the logistics challenges
here are enormous and when you start
like being a very significant percentage
of an industry you can't over capacitize
it's not realistic
um
and some of these things like you said
like well you dual Source or triple
Source you can do that maybe for small
things but you can't do it for big
things because
if you're if you're triple sourced and
one of it's like having a plane with
three engines where if any of the three
engines fails you crash
it's like you know so
and you you have to either over
capacitize which drives your capex up
um and it has idle suppliers somewhere
and big warehouses or you designed to
some overage that's you know reasonable
um
and then you have expedite costs because
inevitably this something goes wrong
somewhere and you've got to fly things
around
um
so it's really just the the rate of
progress is the rate at which we are
able to scale a uh 10 000 Logistics
problems
um most significant of those is the cell
production
um
and so we we actually
deliberately try to overdo
cell production or self Supply
um
to have that exceed what is needed in
vehicles because if if it goes below
what's needed in vehicles then with the
factories stall
um
so but then what do you do with all
these extra cells it's like well okay so
the the much easier thing to scale up
and down is is powerwol and mega pack
output stationary storage
so we can then over capacitize in cells
and packs and scale production of
stationary storage which is much easier
to scale than vehicle production
so that's strategically I think a good
thing
um
yeah I mean the capex for mega pack is
Tiny compared to capex for vehicles
and also mega pack demand is quasi
infinite it basically as long as we are
competitive with utilities we can tell
as many like
it's it's yeah
cause the infinite demand for that
really for multi-terror many terawatt
hours and we've got a long way to go to
get to many terawatt hours per year
then
let's go to Dan
thank you Dan Leedy Barclays
um I think we know competitive Dynamics
differ significantly by region you know
cost Dynamics differ by region we saw
that with your China gigafactory far
superior cost to what you had free month
I realized it was a new Factory but
there are clearly different Dynamics so
to what extent are the the cost
strategies that you've laid out today do
they differ by region or uh or is there
more of a global one-size-fits-all
approach on reducing cost
he was talking
um yeah I think uh um we're pretty
consistent on the strategy here but
we'll try it as as much localized as
possible
um like in China 95 is over 95 percent
of our supply chain are localized
um all the way from a first tier the
second tierium that the third tier
um and that give us
a generator tremendous savings on Cox
and we also have a very localized
um
labor force and we have access to a
skill the labor force in the region and
Jan's Delta region in Shanghai I'm
particularly referring to
um and
um among over 30 000 of employees in
China we have probably
um less than 20 expats so it's a you
know very deep localization we have done
there to be able to
have such cost structure and we try to
replicate this approach elsewhere in in
different gig factories of course you
know the supplier base that are
different
um the um you know the labor markets are
different region by region the country
by country but we try our best to to
localize
um yeah and
um I think that's that's absolutely
um
give us an advantage to compete with the
auto EMS around the globe
another thing is you we have this direct
selling mode like Zach said you know it
will save a tremendous money on Opex as
well we have full control over all the
expenditures across the
um the company and you know we don't
spend money on on marketing or
advertising everything we saved and will
become you know the value we can offer
to the consumers so that part on that
part we also follow pretty consistent
strategy over the years
I mean certainly the manufacturing stuff
that Colin Pete and myself talked about
whether you make it here or you make it
in Europe or you make it in Asia it
applies everywhere we think about that
from the ground up not not specific to
any region
yeah just one thing I would add to Tom's
point about localization into lars's
Point here and I would actually say that
we're moving in a direction of more
standardization in terms of our
factories and our processes and our cost
reduction approaches so as we've been
thinking about the Next Generation
platform we've been thinking about the
volume that we aspire to build against
that how many individual Factories do we
need to build and what is the fastest
possible way to expand that footprint
around the world
uh what we've done with model Y is each
Factory is an incremental Improvement of
the previous Factory which requires
engineering hours engineering span for
each Factory design and then you end up
with factories that are slightly
different from each other and as we move
towards the Next Generation platform I
think the the term you use Lars is copy
paste
so to get it right from the first time
you know certainly there will be things
that we learn and we replicate and we
make adjustments to but try to have as
much standardization and commonization
as possible which allows us to go as
quickly as possible with expansion
on the site
thanks two questions one for Zach one
for a shark so for Zach how do you think
about a long-term
growth and operating margins for the
business and when we look at 150 275
billion in cap access the remaining
balance of that is that essentially the
capex guidance through 2030. for a shock
the multi-trip Reconstruction that you
highlighted how is that different from
what mobileye does what the REM app that
they have and can you give us any color
on the ap4 hardware
so with respect to operating margins
you know we intend to continue to
improve operating expenses as a
percentage of Revenue over time
and we're continuing to take cost out of
our products and try to keep gross
margins in a place that's healthy as
well
and so you know from the hardware
perspective of the business you know
it's our expectation that we'll continue
to stay in a healthy place over time
uh and then there's a software portion
that's added on top of that and so Elon
has commented on this many times about
the impact that full self-driving
software can have on the economics of
the business and in that space you know
profitability operating margins would be
impacted dramatically
specifically to your point about capex
guidance you know the intent of that
slide was not to provide specific
guidance but to just be transparent
about internally what our rough
estimates are and to provide context
that we think getting to 20 million
vehicles per year and one terawatt hour
of energy storage is very feasible
relative to our expected cash generation
for the business you know that's that's
a number that will move as we learn we
may choose to vertically integrate more
into things we may find efficiencies
elsewhere to the whole conversation we
were having earlier about do we do
mining do we not do mining but the
entire point is to say that that this is
something that's entirely possible based
upon our forecast
regarding the multitude pre-construction
uh my point I was trying to make was
that we want a auto label most of the
data and we can collect data from the
fleet and then reconstruct local areas
that can act as supervision for those
clips since we want to build a scalable
self-driving system we don't want to
really rely on HD Maps or anything even
though we could like trivially build
something using the same technology but
this is mostly for auto labeling and
this provides like precise 3D labels for
all the video sequences involved in the
reconstruction
uh something that's uh I don't know if
we touched on this much but in terms of
training we we have one of the biggest
neural net Training Systems in the world
and that
we expect to increase that capability by
an order of magnitude by the end of this
year
and probably another order of magnitude
by the end of next year
with some combination of Nvidia and dojo
so
much of the scale of that is quite
um daunt on people it's enormous
maybe the final two questions one from
Alex and one from Chris
okay Alex Potter with Piper
um so I definitely want to ask Drew or
or anybody else up there for an update
on on dry battery electrode right so if
you're trying to over capacitize towards
cells
scale a lot of this that clearly there's
a lot of moving pieces and it's a
complex sort of Orchestra with the
supply chain but a lot of it comes down
to dry battery electrode at least to me
so how are you trending that was the
most fascinating part of the factory
tour for me and looking through that
window and seeing that this is clearly
not a science project but anything that
you're willing to disclose yields um
progress where you are today versus
where you thought you were going to be
yeah thanks
um
uh yeah I mean as you saw right like
it's this is this is a real factory
making a lot of dry electrode in an
automated fashion
um we've made a lot of progress uh
it's it's a it's a spectrum like we
we're perfectionists and we we have
clear end goals
um and we are every week that goes by
making progress towards those end goals
whether it's speed of the tool yield of
the of that process or the downstream
process
um
we we haven't stalled out yet on the
rate of progress either and that's both
on the anode and the cathode side
um and I think the the great thing about
where we are with the over capacity that
Elon mentioned is it's giving us the
opportunity to experiment
as we go rather than just being like
stuck to something that uh we happen to
kick off a year and a half ago and it is
here something that Elon has said to the
team many times is it's okay to scrap
equipment or money it's not okay to
scrap time so the way we've been
approaching it is probabilistically what
do we think is the most likely thing to
succeed and even actually in the factory
here you saw more than one anode line
that they are actually operating two
slightly different versions of the the
final process step of the powder
entering the tool and it's a competition
you know which is going to be more
higher yield which is going to perform
better and we have the luxury to be able
to do that and we're taking full
advantage of it to advance the
technology as quickly as possible
the the dry electrode problem is is
really quite a hard problem uh I mean we
acquired Maxwell really just for the dry
electrode uh technology but uh just just
illustrates what a gigantic Gap there is
between something working at small scale
and at large scale
um and we've had a very an extremely
talented team of Engineers working on
sort of scaling the dry electrode
process and having it be reliable uh
consistent and
we've been grinding hard literally and
figuratively on this for quite a while
it seems likely that we will be able to
scale it to volume this year
yeah yeah I mean we're basically
increasing the output week over week uh
like roughly 1K a week per quarter is
our internal Target
um and we're you know we're tracking to
that I think the what you saw is
effectively like a ton of material per
hour per tool
it's kind of like hard to like
rationalize like what that really means
um but it's it it's it is it's different
than like oh something works in a lab
it's like well when it's tons of
material per hour
there's just different kinds of problems
like even if you have like point one
percent Escape of like fines into the
enclosure that your equipment is in now
you have a dust problem and you and like
that could short out some Electronics
it's like just things like this
where when you're on a lab scale you
don't even notice it but when you're
doing thousands of tons over the course
of months it's like oh a new failure
mode we found and that's where we're at
um but we're we're knocking those out
though
um and and the team is grinding through
through it but but progress every week
and the last question from Chris
thanks for taking a question I have a
few follow-ups on the next gen vehicle
um first when do you think we'll get a
look at it maybe a prototype
um second are there any details that you
think you can share in terms of the the
size the content the performance and
then third I think you mentioned that
you would produce it in other plants in
addition to Mexico should we take that
to mean that you can launch it at an
existing plant before you're finished
constructing the new plant in Mexico
uh I think we'll actually have to
probably decline that answer uh
we will have a proper sort of product
event but uh that would be jumping the
gun if we were to answer your questions
maybe another question if this
yeah yeah
I don't know anyone
will will day enough
I have two questions this has really
been a very impressive afternoon thank
you so much Elon I'm curious as you've
doubled and you'll double again
how what you've learned about sort of
managing a larger Enterprise and what
you might have to you know do to manage
a bigger Enterprise and then secondly
I'm curious on your thoughts on how you
know generative Ai and you know these
rapid breakthroughs in AI in the last
months could help you make cars sort of
you know less hard to make
thank you
I don't see AI helping us make cars
anytime soon
um
at that point I mean
at no point any of us working big
problems
so we'll just chill out
I mean I'm a little worried about the AI
stuff
I think it's uh showing I don't know
which we should be concerned about
uh
I don't know I think we should need some
kind of like regulatory Authority or
something it's overseeing AI
development and just making sure that
it's operating within the public
interest and
you know it's quite a dangerous
quite dangerous technology
and I I fear I may have done some things
to accelerate it which is
I don't know
so
I mean some of the AI stuff I think is
just obviously useful like what we're
doing with
self-driving
[Music]
which is you know some people think is
an AGI type problem I don't think it's
quite an AGI problem but it's
certainly requires
very sophisticated neural Nets because
the the road system is designed for eyes
and biological neural Nets so naturally
the analog to that is
cameras with uh
digital neural Nets
and
the other thing we found is there's just
there's a
if you actually look at our neural net
architecture in the car it's
kind of insane frankly uh that's upon
that's upon that's upon Nets yeah the
visualization tool crashes when you open
yeah because it's like so complicated
that no one can visualize this right now
yeah it's hard to visually yeah just
like literally it looks insane
um so I guess something like that's
happening in our brains while we drive
around which is pretty wild
um
so
you know
I don't know
um
like Tesla's doing good things in AI
I don't know this one stresses me out so
I don't know what you think you should
say about it
you know
um
okay given at seven o'clock I think
that's all the time we have
thank you very much for coming and thank
you
foreign
[Music]